madame la ministre la parole est à
Madame Nathalie Goulet rapporteur
spécial de la commission des finances
pour une durée de 7
minutes
vous avez la parole ma cherre collègue
merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre monsieur
les rapporteur monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur général
mes chers collègues je suis très
heureuse et très honorée de rapporter
aujourd'hui le budget de l'action
extérieure de l'État pour les budgets
notamment des Affaires étrangères me
rappelant que j'avais été une dizaine
d'années dans cette
commission nous examinons donc ces
crédits d'action extérieure de l'État
mon intervention se concentrera sur deux
points euh le premier porte sur la
présentation générale euh des crédits de
la mission pour 2024 force de constater
que le budget de la mission était très
largement orienté par les conclusions
des états généraux de la diplomatie qui
se sont tenus d'octobre 2022 à mars 2023
ce travail de réflexion s'inscrivait en
réponse à un mouvement social qui a
traversé le ministère en juin 2022 suite
à la réforme du corps diplomatique la
conclusion de ces états généraux a été
l'occasion pour le gouvernement
d'annoncer une augmentation de 700
équivalents temps plein et de 20 % du
budget d'ici 2027 cette ambition est
traduite dans le budget 2024 par une
progression des crédits de 3 milliards
et demi d'euros en autorisation
d'engagement comme en crédit de paiement
par rapport à l'exercice précédent les
crédits progressent de près de 290
millions d'euros soit une augmentation
de 6 % sur l'ensemble de la mission
cette hausse des crédit s'accompagne de
l'ouverture de 165 équivalent en plein
sur l'ensemble des programmes de la
mission il me semble c'est que cette
augmentation généralisée soulève
toutefois trois points de vigilance
madame la ministre premièrement il
faudra être attentif à éviter l'effet
saupoudrage des crédits les choix des
répartitions des crédits doivent
s'inscrire en cohérence avec nos
priorités stratégique et géographique à
cet égard je pense qu'il est nécessaire
de mieux mesurer l'effet levier des
dépenses de l'action extérieure
deuxièmement il semble que la
programmation de certaines dépenses
devait être rapidement précisée par les
responsables des programmes la
ventilation de certains crédits et des
emplois m'est apparu imprécise au cours
des auditions certaines lignes
budgétaires sont renseignées de matière
cibiline à l'image de celle dédié aux
dépenses d'intervention des ambassades
laallocation des 165 nouveaux
équivalents temps plein n'a pas encore
terminé pour au moins un programme de la
mission troisièmement nous devons
veiller à la bonne exécution de
certaines dépenses je pense notamment
aux dépenses immobilier qui ont pu faire
l'objet d'une sous-consommation lors des
exercices précédents pour prendre en
compte ces points de vigilance afin
d'assurer une contribution de la mission
à l'effort de redressement des comptes
publics la commission des finances a
adopté un amendement proposant de
diminuer 30 de 30 millions d'euros les
crédits de la mission nous en discuerons
tout à l'heure d'autre part cet
amendement prévoit une diminution de 5
millions sur les dépenses de protocole
dont l'augmentation semble excessivement
élevée au regard des conférences
internationales qui seront organisées en
France en 2024 il réduit également de 5
millions d'euros les dépenses
d'immobilier dont la programmation
semble insuffisante et qui font l'objet
régulier d'une sous-exécution d'autre
part cet amendement propose une
réduction de 20 millions d'euros sur les
crédits d'intervention à disposition des
ambassades et des services centraux en
matière culturelle universitaire et
scientifique je considère que la
doctrine d'engagement de ces dépenses
n'est pas suffisamment précisée au
regard de la Haus des crédits de la
mission en 2024 cette mesure d'économie
reste limitée et Nobert pas les
capacités du ministère de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères à répondre aux
objectifs de la politique étrangère de
la France j'aborde maintenant le second
point la présentation plus détaillée du
programme 105 ce dernier regroupe les
contributions internationales et les
dépenses liées à l'administration
centrale et au rizau diplomatique à
l'étranger en premier lieu concernant
les contributions internation
il y a un petit bruit de fond monsieur
le Président en premier lieu concernant
les contributions internationales et
européennes les dépenses sont pour
partie dépendantes d'engagements
internationaux de la France pour
financer les organisations
multilatérales au total les contribution
internationale hors contribution
européenne s'élèveront à 729 millions
d'euros en 2024 en hausse de 3 % par
rapport à 2023 je rappelle qu'une partie
de nos contributions intern national et
versé en devis sont exposés au risque de
change comp ceus cette incertitude
d'évaluation des changes à moyen terme
le ministère des Affaires étrangères à
activé le mécanisme de couverture de
change ce qui est évidemment une très
bonne procédure une partie de la hausse
des contributions pour 2024 s'explique
par le doublement du financement de la
facilité européenne de paix cette
dernière a été largement sollicitée et
justement sollicité pour financer l'
l'aide apportée à l'Ukraine dans sa
résistance à l'aggression russe en CE
second lieu s'agissant des crédits de
l'administration centrale et du réseau
diplomatique la hausse des crédits
entend traduire le réarmement de notre
diplomatie le ministère portera un
effort particulier sur certaines
dépenses présentées comme stratégiques
je pense notamment aux dépense
improprement dit de communication en
réalité il s'agit des budgets de veille
à la désinformation et donc à la
communication d'influence madame la
ministre je pense qu'il faudrait trouver
un meilleur vocabulaire une meilleure
inition la communication me semble pas
complètement pertinent comme vocabulaire
pour couvrir l'action qui est couverte
par par ces crédits donc veille à la
reposte à la désinformation c'est quand
même un poste extrêmement important
communication en terme de vocabulaire
n'y répondra peut-être pas forcément le
contexte international dégradé explique
le renforcement des dépenses de sécurité
en France comme à l'étranger les crédit
de la sécurité à l'étranger devrait
atteindre 67 millions d'euros en crédit
de paiement le centre de crise et de
soutien en du qu
d'orset mobilisé dans les évacuations de
nos ressortissants voit d'ailleurs sa
dotation renforcée ce qui est totalement
légitime s'agissant en particulier de
protéger nos ambassades par des mesures
de sécurité dites passives cela semble
aussi évidemment justifié compte tenu du
contexte international notamment au
Sahel donc ces précautions sont
évidemment nécessaires donc sous réserve
de l'adoption de de l'amendement de la
commission et des avis éclairés de mon
excellent collègue Rémi
Ferraud je vous propose d'adopter les
crédits de la mission action extérieure
de l'État ainsi que l'article 50A qui
est rattaché je vous remercie merci
chers collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Rémy Ferraud rapporteur spécial de la
commission des finances vous avez la
parole mon cher collègue pour 7
minutes merci monsieur le Président
excusez ma voix madame la ministre chers
collègues comme bienent de l'indiquer
Nathalie Goulet les crédits de la
mission action extérieure de l'État
connaissent une hausse substantielle
dans ce projet de loi de finance
j'évoquerai pour ma part le programme
151 qui regroupe les moyens dédiés au
Français de l'étranger au réseau consula
en 2024 l'administration consulaire doit
doit poursuivre sa démarche de
modernisation notamment finalisant la
rénovation des outils numériques de nos
administrations consulaires la
dématérialisation de l'état civil des
Français nés à l'étranger ou ayant eu un
événement d'état civil engagé en 2019 en
est un bon exemple puisque le ministère
espère pouvoir engager en 2024 la
dernière étape de ce projet à savoir
l'ouverture en ligne du registre
électronique la plateforme France
consulaire devrait également continuer
d'être déployée cette année et ce centre
d'appel vise à soulager les services
consulaires des demandes téléphoniques
il est pour l'instant limité à l'Europe
mais doit être étendu en Afrique euh à
l'Afrique pardon au courant 2024 puis au
reste du monde il faut néanmoins veiller
à ce que cette évolution soit bien un
plus pour nos postes consulaires et
n'entraînne pas un amoindrissement de
l'accueil physique ensuite l'année 2024
et comme vous le savez une année
d'élection les services consulaires
seront particulièrement sollicités à
cette occasion et le programme reçoit
pour cela un abandement exceptionnel de
1,1 million d'euros en plus d'un
transfert du ministère de l'intérêt ur
enfin les bourses scolaires constituent
les principales dépenses d'intervention
du programme
151 je sais que nos collègues élus des
Français de l'étranger ils sont très
attentifs ces bourses sont versées
directement aux établissements elles
permettent de soutenir les familles les
plus modestes pour accéder à
l'enseignement français à l'étranger en
2023 l'ensemble des crédits avaiit été
consommés conduisant à liquider la soute
de la EFE pour 2024 le montant de
l'enveloppe des bourses sera donc de 118
millions d'euros et je pense que nous
devrons être à la fois attentif à la
consommation de cette enveloppe dans son
intégralité pour éviter la
reconstitution d'une soute mais aussi
attentif à ce que le montant soit
suffisant dans un contexte de
difficultés social et de forte inflation
ensuite concernant le programme 185 le
budget renforce les moyens de notre
diplomatie d'influence puisque les
crédits du programme progressent de 5,7
%. prier irement cette hausse des moyens
vise à renforcer l'attractivité de la
France dans les domaines culturels
scientifiques universitaires et même si
cela reste modeste par rapport à la
politique d'influence d'autres pays je
veux saluer cet effort enfin en faveur
du développement de notre rayonnement
ainsi l'enveloppe des bourses en faveur
des étudiants étrangers est renforcé de
6 millions d'euros l'objectif porté par
le ministère et son opérateur Campus
France étant d'attirer en priorité d'AV
avantage d'étudiants d'Afrique et
d'indo-pacifique j'estime pour ma part
que cet effort est positif d'autant que
chaque étudiant étranger accueilliis en
France sera un futur ambassadeur
potentiel de notre pays et c'est
extrêmement important dans la
mondialisation d'aujourd'hui cependant
comme je l'avais rappelé dans mon
intervention l'an dernier nous devrons
rester vigilants car ces crédits sont
régulièrement sous-exécuté et on peut
s'intéresser à la marge de manœuvre
budgétaire qu'il que cela permet y
compris pour encaisser les effets de
l'inflation ou bien regretter cette
sous-exécution par manque de
volontarisme politique en la matière
jusqu'à présent
ensuite le projet de loi de finance
augmente les crédits d'intervention
pilotés par les service de coopération
et d'action culturelle leur emploi nous
paraît cependant trop peu détaillé
Nathalie Goulet l'a dit et interroge sur
la doctrine de consommation des crédits
certes la logique de gestion au plus
près du terrain est un bon point mais
cela ne peut se faire au prix de la
redevabilité des comptes et donc nous
pouvons considérer qu'il faut modérer
cette hausse ou bien comme je le fais
personnellement dire qu'il faut que nous
soyons attentifs à l'exécution de ces
crédits lors de nos travaux de
contrôle enfin il s'agit de soutenir le
développement de l'enseignement français
à l'étranger avec ce programme 185 et à
cet égard je voudrais souligner deux
points d'attention d'une part l'objectif
de ement du nombre d'élèves d'ici 2030
paraît aujourd'hui inatteignable et même
si plusieurs initiatives intéressantes
sont abondé par ce projet de loi de
finance cela supposerait une croissance
du nombre d'élèves de 5 % par an alors
que c'est 0,5 % cette année d'autre part
je pense qu'il faut être vigilant sur
l'évolution de la subvention pour charge
de servicees public versé à la EFE si
elle est maintenue cette année à un
niveau conséquent de l'ordre de 455
millions d'euros l'inflation reste élevé
dans de nombreux pays pourrait peser sur
les frais de scolarité et il apparaît de
que indispensable que l'enseignement
demeure pour nos compatriotes vivant à
l'étranger un véritable service public
donc que la part de contribution des
familles reste stable nous devrons y
être attentif cette année la question de
la capacité de financement des projets
de long terme de la de l'agence reste
également ouvert puisque ces capacités
d'endettement sont très contraintes par
le cadre budgétaire il y a des travaux
lourds entretien énergétique et de
rénovation des établissements qui
doivent conduire à des besoins
d'investissement importants en ce sens
le rapport demandé par l'article 5A du
projet de loi devrait nous permettre
d'envisager une évolution du mode de
financement de la
EFE pour conclure je souhaiterais donc
présenter la position de la Commission
sur les crédits de la mission j'estime
pour ma part que la hausse des moyens
qui est accordé à la diplomatie
française est nécessaire et bien venu le
premier rapport des consultations menées
dans le cadre des états généraux de la
diplomatie a été de souligner la volonté
des agents du ministère de prévenir la
dégradation de notre outil diplomatique
ces dernières années les les mesures
d'économie ont affaibli les capacité du
quai d'orset à mettre en œuvre la
politique étrangère de la France et à
assurer une présence consulaire et
culturelle efficace pour un gain
budgétaire en faveur des finances de
l'État extrêmement limité or dans le
contexte géopolitique nous devons être
en mesure de déployer une véritable
diplomatie d'influence et de venir en
soutien à nos compatriotes à l'étranger
la commission des finances vous invite
donc chers collègues à approuver les
crédit de la mission action extérieure
de l'État et à adopté l'article 550A
rattaché à la mission comme l'a déjà dit
avant moi notre collègue Nathalie Goulet
je vous
remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Philippe Paul
en remplacement de Madame Valérie Boyer
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des affaires étrangères de la défense et
des forces armées pour 3 minutes vous
avez la parole mon cher
collègue bien monsieur le Président
Madame la ministre mes chers collègues
en 2024 les crédits du programme 10 5
progressent de près de 8,7 % par rapport
à la loi de finance initiale pour 2023
pour atteindre 2,26 milliard EUR le
ministère se félicite de la hausse
inédite semble-t-il depuis 2005 de 13 %
des dépenses hors
rémunération sans doute mais le
doublement de la contribution française
à la facilité européenne pour la paix
destiné à aider l'Ukraine explique
presque la moitié de cet effort le plus
gros poste parmi les dépenses
d'intervention est celui des crédits
consacrés aux contributions
internationales ça hausse d'une petite
centaine de million d'euros s'explique
par l'effet échange et la revalorisation
de certaines contributions
l'effort des contributions volontaires
lui ne représente que 2,3 milliards
d'euros ce qui est loin très loin de ce
qu'on font nos amis britanniques ou
allemand ainsi que l'ont montré nos
collègues de la commission des finances
l'an dernier l'impact de ces
contributions n'est pas même facile à
illustrer et mériterait un examen plus
approfondi les crédits nouveaux
permettront certes d'engager le
réarmement de notre diplomatie au sens
où pour la deuxème année cons motive le
ministère recrutera en 2024 le ministère
prévoit l'embauche de 165 et dans le
périmètre de la mission action
extérieure de l'État dont une bonne
centaine au titre du programme 105 c'est
bien mais je rappelle que ces effectifs
ont perdu 3000 ETP entre 2007 et 2021
cette ha c'est la première marche d'une
programmation présentée par le chef de
l'État en mars à l'issue des états
généraux de la diplomatie convoqué pour
apaiser les craintes suscitées par la
réforme du statut des diplomates près
des 3/4 ont à ce jour opté pour le cadre
des administrateurs de l'État mais il
est douteux que les inquiétudes soient
toutes paiser quoi qu'il en soit
l'agenda de la transformation suit son
cours l'organigramme du ministère a été
revu le 1er septembre dernier et de
nombreux chantiers ont été ouvert
touchant au concours à la qualité de vie
au travail à la formation à la mobilité
ou à la politique sociale du ministère
un mot de quelques aspects de
fonctionnement la sécurité diplomatique
sera correctement financée les
événements de l'été au nigerre en en
montré l'efficacité les dépenses de
protocole affichent une hausse notable
mais qui semblent justifié par le nombre
d'événements internationaux prévu et qui
aideront à la
professionalisation de l'organisation de
conférence internationale un mot des
contraintes immobilières en raison de
l'évolution des méthodes de travail du
besoin des task forces de formation de
crise et de la rationalisation du parc
engagé n guerre les locaux en
administration centrale sont désormais
saturés dans ces conditions abriter les
700 ETP promis d'ici 4 ans par le chef
de l'État sera une véritable gageur
enfin la tendance au renement des moyens
de notre notre diplomatie semble révolu
et c'est heureux aussi la commission des
affaires étrangères est-elle favorable à
l'adoption des crédits du programme 105
proposé par le gouvernement merci chers
collègues la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Jean-Baptiste Lemoine
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des affaires étrangères de la défense et
des forces armées pour 3 minutes la
parole monsieur le ministre merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre madame monsieur le rapporteur
mes chers collègues bon au sein de ce
budget offensif avec Valérie Boyer nous
avons examiné de plus près trois aspects
qui nous semblent fondamentaux dans
l'environnement géopolitique
particulièrement dangereux du moment
d'abord les moyens dédiés à la gestion
de crise et c'est vrai que la France
dispose en la matière d'un savoir-faire
envié à l'étranger avec ce le CDCS le
centre de crise et de soutien et je veux
saluer à cette tribune l'action des
personnels du CDCS et des renforts avec
la CroixRouge avec également nos anciens
diplomates qui n'hésitent pas à venir et
bien en appui et en soutien c'est grâce
à eux que la France parvient d'une part
à rapatrier nos Français établis hors de
France lorsqu'il le faut mais également
des des nationaux d'autres États membres
de l'Union européenne et puis que nous
pouvons déployer vite et fort une action
humanitaire je le dis alors que nous
sommes à quelques jours de la Conférence
nationale humanitaire et des moyens
significatifs ont déjà été alloué et ces
crises force êre constaté qu'elles sont
de plus en plus nombreuses
fréquente grave depuis le début de
l'année 2023 on pense au séisme en
Turquie et en Syrie à l'évacuation au
Soudan opération Sagittaire aux
événements au Gabon en Libye au Maroc au
carabach au Proche-Orient désormais et
donc tout cela justifie une augmentation
des budgets de fonctionnement du CDCS de
l'ordre de 15 % cette année et également
un accroissement de ces ETP 2ème
fonction significative que nous avons
voulu examiner la communication et
l'influence puisque effectivement euh
cela va bénéficier d'un effort
additionnel de 2 million d'euros l'an
prochain pour renforcer les effectifs de
la direction de la communication et de
la presse pour mettre aussi en œuvre ses
ambitions en matière de lutte contre la
désinformation euh avec euh la création
récente d'une sous-direction chargée de
la veille et de la stratégie ce qui est
bienvenu qui va pouvoir euh euh faire
euh cette veille sur les réseaux
élaborer aussi une repost et euh je
crois qu'il faut souligner euh que euh
le qu d'ersil communique non seulement
en six langues depuis la centrale mais
en cinquantaine de langues
euh nationale ou local ce qui montre
notre capacité et bien voilà nous faire
entendre partout et puis enfin nous
avons voulu insister sur la coopération
de sécurité de défense puisque
contrairement à ce que certains
pourraient laisser à croire la demande
de de France ne faiblit pas en la
matière que ce soit en Afrique de
l'Ouest ou ailleurs dans le monde nous
avons d'ailleurs créé de nouvelles envr
récemment au montenégro au Sri Lanka et
l'idée d'accroître de 40 % l'offre de
formation et d'investir davantage
certaines zones comme l'Indo-Pacifique
et les Balcans donc dans ce monde fait
d'accumulation de crise de délitement
d'un système multilatéral et d'émergence
de nouveau thé d'opération comme le
théâtre informational et bien écoutez ne
boudons pas notre plaisir de voir le rè
moment de notre diplomatie réellement
engagé la commission s'est prononcée
favorablement sur les crédits du
programme 105 je vous remercie merci mon
cher collègue la parole est à Madame
Catherine dum rorteur pour avis de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées pour 3
[Applaudissements]
minutes vous avez la parole ma cher
collègu merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
le projet de loi de finances pour 2024 a
vocation à transcrire budgétairement le
réarmement de la diplomatie française
annoncé par le président de la
République à l'occasion de la clôture
des états généraux de la diplomatie le
programme 185 diplomatie culturel et
d'influence verra ainsi ses crédits
progressés de 62 millions d'euros en
2024 pour atteindre 806 millions et
cette trajectoire ascendante devrait se
poursuivre dans les années à venir nous
en donnons acte au
gouvernement dans le domaine culturel le
PLF pour 2024 prévoit 4 millions d'euros
de crédit supplémentaires
au titre de la mise en œuvre des actions
de la feuille de route de l'influence je
voudrais citer en particulier le
programme villa Albertine qui constitue
un axe fort de notre politique
d'influence aux États-Unis et qui
bénéficiera d'une enveloppe d'un million
d'euros s'agissant des Alliances
françaises 800000 € sont prévu au titre
de la coordination et la création de
nouvelles alliances soit un montant
proche des besoins exprimés en 2023 par
ailleurs une dotation de 800000 € est
inscrite pour la mise en place d'un fond
d'aide aux alliances en difficulté
certaines d'entre elles à l'instar
d'ailleurs de Cell de Sao Paulo doivent
en faire l'objet doivent faire l'objet
d'un soutien renforcé s'agissant des
instituts français leur dotations seront
abondé de 4 million d'euros en 2024 de
plus des crédits supplémentaires sont
prévus afin de poursuivre la
revalorisation des rémunérations des
agents des établissements à autonomie
financière j'en viens maintenant
maintenant à la question de
l'attractivité universitaire et
étudiante le regard que nous portons sur
le PLF dans ce domaine est plus nuancé
madame les ministres l'enveloppe de
bourse connaîtra certes une hausse de 6
millions d'euros par rapport à 2023 mais
d'une part le ministère ne semble pas
disposer d'une doctrine claire
concernant l'emploi de ces crédits
supplémentaires et d'autre part
l'ampleur de cette hausse ne semble pas
cohérente avec l'objectif de doublement
du nombre de bourses à l'horizon 2030
aussi madame la ministre pourriez-vous
nous indiquer si le Gouvernement entend
maintenir cette ambition par ailleurs le
montant de la subvention versé à Campus
France constitue un point de vigilance
alors que l'opérateur devrait connaître
un déficit en 2023 enfin le décrochage
relatif de la France dans les
classements internationaux invite à
donner un nouveau souffle à la stratégie
bienvenue en France en s'attaquant
notamment aux questions
structurelles mes chers cè si beaucoup
reste donc à faire pour réarmer
véritablement notre diplomatie
culturelle et d'influence les
orientations prises dans le cadre du
budget pour 2024 nous semble aller dans
le bon sens à cet égard et même si nous
partageons l'objectif de réduire les
déficits publics nous ne pourrons pas
voter l'amendement de la commission des
finances qui propose une réduction des
crédits du programme 185 et oui à
hauteur de 20 millions d'euros à ce
titre la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées a émis un avis favorable à
l'adoption des crédits du programme 185
sans modification je vous remerci merci
ma chère collègue la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Renand
legleu rapporteur pour avis de la
commission des Affaires étrangère de la
défense et des forces
armées pour 3
minutes non je l'ai
pas je vais vous donner la parole va
donner la parole allez-y monsieur Marie
effectivement je ne vous ai pas je ne
vous ai pas dans mon non non il y a pas
de
censure pardon monsieur Leleu la parole
est à Monsieur Didier Marie rapporteur
pour avis de la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense des forces armé
vous avez la parole mon cher
collègue merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
la France dispose d'un outil d'influence
unique au monde avec ses 580
établissements scolaires d'enseignement
français présent dans C 39 pays à cet
égard l'effort porté par le projet de
loi de finance pour 2024 s'il va dans le
bon sens nous semble globalement
insuffisant au regard des ambitions
réaffirmées en juillet dernier lors du
Conseil d'Orientation interministérielle
de l'enseignement français à l'étranger
en premier lieu la progression du
montant de la subvention versée à la EFE
de 8 millions d'euros ne se traduira pas
par un accroissement de ces moyens mais
permettra uniquement de compenser la
moitié du coût lié à la réforme du
statut des personnes détaché en incluant
la hausse du point l'indice de la
fonction publique ce sont près de 22
millions d'euros qui resteront à la
charge de la EFE auxquel il convient
d'ajouter les effets de l'inflation
estimés à plus de 7 millions et demi ce
surcout aura un effet direct sur le
niveau des contributions versé par les
établissements et donc sur les droits de
scolarité payés par les familles par
ailleurs l'objectif présidentiel de
doubler les effectifs d'élèves à
l'horizon 2030 bien que réaffirmé en
2023 semble hors de porté au regard des
moyens engagés et de la tendance
constatée ces dernières années en second
lieu d'importants freins doivent encore
être levés concernant en particulier des
questions immobilières pour permettre
une croissance du réseau en tant
qu'organisme diverses administrations
centrales la EFE ne peut pas avoir
recours aux emprunts de plus de 12 mois
cette interdiction nuit à la réalisation
d'opérations pourtant essentielles pour
maintenir la qualité et l'attractivité
du réseau ainsi selon la EFE les besoins
immobiliers non satisfaits au titre du
schéma immob est en cours s'élverrait à
près de 100 millions d'euros les
premiers éléments de chiffrage pour les
années à venir laissent apparaître des
besoins de l'ordre de 200 millions
d'euros cette évaluation reste
évidemment à affiner mais elle constitue
un indicateur de l'ampleur des
investissements nécessaires c'est
pourquoi nous demandons que soit
inscrite dès le budget 2025 une
subvention pour charge d'investissement
destinée au financement des
investissements immobiliers des
établissements en gestion directe
s'agissant des établissements convention
partenaire nous avons constaté des
retards dans la mise en œuvre du nouveau
dispositif d'octroi de la garantie de
l'État un seul arrêté a ainsi été pris à
ce jour alors que 11 dossiers ont reçu
un avis favorable depuis avril 2022 nous
demandons donc que les arrêtés d'octroit
garantie soient pris le plus rapidement
possible afin de permettre aux
établissements concernés de lancer leur
projets immobilier chers collègues je
conclurai en disant que ce projet de
budget laisse un goût d'inachevé
pourtant la direction prise nous semble
être la bonne aussi réduire les consacré
à notre diplomatie culturelle et
d'influence comme le propose
l'amendement de la commission des
finances apparaîtrait par conséquent
contradictoire avec les ambitions
affichées dans le contexte géopolitique
actuel et alors que nos compétiteurs
investissent massivement cette fonction
stratégique la Commission s'est donc
prononcé en faveur de l'adoption des
crédits du programme 185 et ceci sans
modification je vous remercie merci mon
cher collègue la parole est maintenant à
notre collègue Renand legle rapport teur
pour avis de la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées pour 3 minutes vous avez la
parole mon cher
collègue bien monsieur le Président
Madame la ministre mes chers collègues
pour ce programme 151 français à
l'étranger et affaires consulaire comme
pour les deux autres programmes de la
mission action extérieure de l'État ce
projet de budget poursuit et confirme la
trajectoire de hausse entamée l'an
dernier notre commission a donc donné un
avis favorable il convient de se
féliciter que notre diplomatie si
longtemps maltraité retrouve
progressivement des moyens à la hauteur
de ses missions de plus le programme 151
reçoit cette année toute sa part de
l'augmentation des crédits avec une
hausse de 11,6 % pour 8,9 % sur
l'ensemble de la mission c'est
appréciable les rapporteurs y ont
regretté l'an dernier que les crédits
progressent moins vite que ceux du
réseau
diplomatique dans le détail
l'augmentation bénéficie à la
quasi-ttalité des postes de dépenses
assemblée des Français de l'étranger
réseau consulaire modernisation de
l'administration consulaire aide à la
scolarité avec une augmentation
significative des bourses
scolaires une exception notable
cependant l'aide sociale qui est
simplement reconduite sous réserve
d'éventuels ajustements en gestion
pourquoi ne pas reconnaître d'emblé que
le contexte inflationniste mondial et la
situation de crise dans de nombreux pays
justifie un renforcement du secours à
nos compatriotes il est également
regrettable que le réel effort
budgétaire ne se traduise que très
imparfaitement dans la progression des
effectifs pour ce qui est des affaires
consulaires c'est regrettable car notre
réseau consulaire est mis sous pression
par la reprise de la demande de visa
après la pandémie le ministère traite
l'afflux de demande par un système de
vacation en faisant appel à des renforts
venus de la DFAE la direction des
Français à l'étranger et des affaires
consulaires mais le financement de ce
système qui repose en partie sur les
recettes de visa des an années
précédente n'est pas
optimale il faudra à long terme apporter
des réponses structurelles à cette
situation le rapport présenté en avril
dernier par Paul armmelin sur la
politique de visa décrit des consulats
débordés voir en souffrance et propose
un certain nombre de solutions que le
ministère s'engage à
expertiser autre balise importante de ce
budget la poursuite du déploiement du
service France consulaire une plateforme
téléphonique pour répondre aux demandes
les plus courantes des Français de
l'étranger et soulager ainsi les postes
consulaires à la cour neuve où nous
avons pu constater que le service
fonctionnait de manière tout à fait
satisfaisante les téléconseillers sont
supervisés par un plateau composé de 14
agents du ministère qui reprennent les
demandes auxquelles de le premier niveau
ne peut pas répondre et surtout
constitue une base de données mise à
jour en temps réel et ce pour chaque
pays le budget de France consulaire est
double est doublé cette année afin
d'accompagner l'extension du service à
toute l'Europe à la fin 2023 puis à
l'horizon 2025 à tous les fuseaux
horaires entre - 8 et + 8h soit 97 % des
Français de l'étranger il faudra faire
grandir le service en conséquence
notamment le plateau de 2uxè niveau
France consulaire est une initiative
bienvenue qui aidera nos consulats à se
concentrer sur leurs tâches les plus
essentiel à la condition qu'ell ne
servent pas de prétexte à de nouvell
réduction d'effectifs dans le réseau il
y a des demandes que seul un agent sur
place peut traiter le contact humain
dans le réseau consulaire comme ailleurs
n'est pas une variable d' justement je
vous
remercie merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à monsieur Guillaume Gontard
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des affaires étrangères de la défense et
des forces armées vous avez la parole
pour 3 minutes mon cher
collègue merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre je vous présenterai
en complément deux points qui ont attiré
notre attention lors de la préparation
de ce rapport d'abord les crédits des
bourses scolaires alloués sur critères
sociaux aux enfants scolarisés dans le
réseau de l'Agence pour l'enseignement
français à l'étr étranger il s'agit du
premier poste de dépense du programme
hors titre 2 ces crédits sont en
augmentation marqué dans ce projet de
loi de finance à 118 millions d'euros
contre 104,4 millions en 2024 mais en
réalité il s'agit d'une augmentation en
trompeleuil en 2023 le montant prévu en
loi de finance initiale était
insuffisant c'est pourquoi on a eu
recours en gestion au dégel de la
réserve et à la soute reli de montant
non distribués pendant la crise
sanitaire à la fin 2023 les montants ent
alloué s'élève à environ 113,3 million
d'euros c'est-à-dire un montant
supérieur à celui prévu pour 2024 112,6
millions déduction faite de la réserve
mais même avec ces compléments le
montant prévu s'est avéré insuffisant il
a donc fallu recourrir à un dernier
expédient la contribution progressive de
solidarité élégant périphrase pour
désigner un rabot budgétaire appliqué au
montant des bourses cette CPS dont le
taux est normalement fixé à 2 % a donc
été porté à 7 % suscitant
l'incompréhension des parents or il est
à craindre au vu des données budgétaires
que le taux de 7 % soit à nouveau
appliqué cette année il faut reconnaître
que le suivi budgétaire de l'attribution
des bourses est très complexe les
montants votés ne sont pas consommés sur
l'année civile les versements
n'interviennent pas au même moment dans
les pays du rythme Nord et ceux du
rythme Sud les variations de taux de
change peuvent être très importantes
enfin des changements liés à la
scolarisation peuvent intervenir en
cours d'année la EFE a engagé une
refonte de son appli
dédié à la gestion de ces bourses Scolas
qui devrait permettre un suivi plus
étroit et une meilleure prévisibilité il
reste que les expédients comme la hausse
brutale de la CPS ne sont ni vertueux au
point de vue budgétaire ni équitable
vis-à-vis des parents le deuxème point
de vigilance porte sur le concours de
l'État à la catégorie dite aider des
adhérents à la Caisse des Français de
l'étranger CFE pour rappel la CFE est un
organisme de droit privé mais titulaire
d'une délégation de service public
offrant une protection sociale
facultative à nos compatriotes de
l'étranger les foyers se situant en
dessous d'un seuil de de 22000 € annuel
en 2023 qui définit la catégorie aid
bénéficie d'un tarif d'adhésion
préférentiel à la CFE fixé à 210 € par
trimestre le coût de ce dispositif est
pris en charge par l'État et par la CFE
mais les parts respectives n'ayant pas
été fixé le concours de l'État est allé
en se réduisant depuis 2016 il est fixé
à 380000 €. or le coût du dispositif qui
concerernit 2203 contrats en 2022 et lui
allait croissant pendant que les marges
de manœuvre financière de la CFE diminué
aujourd'hui le dispositif coûte 4
millions d'euros l'État en assume moins
de 10 % contre 25 % en 2011 ce qui est
en jeu c'est la couverture sociale de
nos compatriotes les moins favorisés
l'État devrait donc prendre sa part
d'autant que les montants sont
extrêmement modéré de ces dernières
années le concours de l'État a en
réalité été abondé en gestion atteignant
par exemple 764800 € en 2022 c'est
pourquoi nous vous soumettons un
amendement de doublement de la
contribution de l'État pour le porter à
760000 € moyenant cet amendement et avec
les réserves et points de vigilance que
nous avons exposé nous proposerons de
donner un avis favorable à ce programme
151 merci merci monsieur le Président la
parole est à Monsieur Claude KNE
rapporteur pour avis de la commission de
la culture de l'éducation et de la
communication pour 3
minutes
vous avez la parole mon chers
collègues merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
comme les orateurs qui m'ont précédé je
me félicite de voir progresser les
crédits accordés à la diplomatie
culturelle et d'influence dans le
contexte géopolitique très préoccupant
que nous connaissons cette évolution
mérite d'être saluée mais plusieurs
bémoles doivent toutois toutefois être
apporté je demeure très sceptique quand
quant à la possibilité d'atteindre
l'objectif présidentiel de doublement
des effectifs du réseau de
l'enseignement français à l'étranger qui
a pourtant été réaffirmé en juillet
dernier la directrice de lafe admet
elle-même que cet objectif est
extrêmement ambitieux et que les
effectifs à la rentrée 2023 étaient
endessà des chiffres espérés la
progression annuelle de seulement 1 %
des effectifs à la rentrée 2023 reste
environ quatre fois en dessà de ceux qui
serait nécessaire
l'augmentation des effectifs est est
plus particulièrement portée par la
hausse du nombre d'élèves étrangers si
actuellement 2 ti3 des élèves de
l'enseignement français à l'étranger
n'ont pas la nationalité française il
devrait être plus de 80 % à l'horizon
2030 je regrette par ailleurs vivement
les difficultés de recrutement des
enseignants détachés dans le réseau en
raison du refus du détachement de la
part des académies à la rentrée 2023 le
nombre de postes vacances sur l'ensemble
du réseau
avait été multiplié par de depuis
l'année dernière en conséquence de plus
en plus de personnel français sont
désormais recr recrutés sur des contrats
locaux ceux qui constituent une
aberration je souhaite enfin saluer
l'action de nos réseaux de diplomatie
culturelle et d'enseignement français à
l'étranger qui exercent actuellement
leur activité dans des zones de guerre
en Ukraine l'Institut français a adapté
un certain nombre de ses activités en
fonction du contexte de guerre qui a
fait apparaître de nouvelles demandes de
la part de nos partenaires Ukrainiens
les six Alliances françaises d'Ukraine
continuent leurs activités
d'enseignement en distantiel et
fonctionne en mode dégradé les deux
établissements français d'enseignement
français de Kiev scolarise encore à ce
jour plus de 300 élèves en Israël le
dispositif culturel français est resté
ouvert à l'exception de l'antenne de
Nazareth le contexte sécuritaire a
engendré un par important d'élèves des 6
établissements d'enseignement français
en Israël jusqu'à 1/ers des effectifs et
le 3 novembre dernier l'Institut
français de Gaza a quant à lui été
touché par une frappe heureusement son
personnel avait été évacué vers le sud
de la bande de Gaza sous le bénéfice de
ces observations madame la ministre la
commission de la culture a émis un avis
favorable à l'adoption du des crédits du
programme
185 pour 2024 je je vous remercie merci
mon cher
collègue dans la suite de notre
discussion je vous rappelle que le temps
de parole attribué à chaque groupe pour
chaque unité de discussion comprend le
temps d'intervention générale et celui
de l'explication de vote par ailleurs le
gouvernement dispose au total de 15
minutes pour intervenir madame la
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier cadiic pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste pour 5
minutes vous avez la parole mon chers
collègues
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues le plan de
réarmement de la diplomatie française
voulu par le Président de la République
nous réjouit madame la ministre il
aboutit cette année encore à une
augmentation du budget de la mission et
du nombre de TP 165 en 2024 en ma
qualité de sénateur représentant les
Français établis hors de France j'ai
plusieurs motifs de satisfaction qui
concerne le programme 151 français à
l'étranger affaires consulaires tout
d'abord l'accélération du déploiement du
service France consulaire avec un
remarquable pragmatisme la nouvelle
directrice des Français de l'étranger
que je salue a réorganisé la plateforme
de réponse téléphonique en Irlande pays
test le consulat de Dublin ne reçoit
plus que 4 % des appels 96 % sont
traités par France consulaire on
comprend pourquoi tous les autres
consulats attendent impatiemment de
bénéficier de ce service la cou
ouverture mondiale est envisagée fin
2025 soit un an plus tôt un an plus tôt
que prévu initialement sans envisager
d'emploi publ supplémentaire autre point
positif la dématérialisation du
renouvellement des passeports pour
éviter de se présenter dans les postes
consulaires elle débutera au Canada et
au Portugal à compté de mars 2024 avec
ma collègue des Français de l'étranger
Olivia Richard nous nous réjouissons
également que soit opérée la première
revalorisation des indemnités des
conseillers des Français de l'étranger
depuis 2014 en fonction du point
d'indice de la fonction publique annoncé
en ouverture de la dernière session de
l'AFE par Olivier bescht cet effort
était très attendu ce sera en effet la
première fois depuis la réforme de 2013
cela ne nous dispensera pas de remettre
à plat les modalités de calcul de ces
indemnités autre avancée pour nos
compatriotes les systèmes internet de
prise de rendez-vous au consulat ou pour
déposer une demande de visa
malheureusement dans certains pays des
officiers ont mis en place des systèmes
astucieux pour préampter tous les
rendez-vous et en faire commerce 200 €
pour un rendez-vous avec le consulat 300
€ pour le service d'état civil 500 pour
un certificat de capacité à mariage nos
compatriotes finissent par penser qu'il
est normal de devoir payer pour avoir
accès au service public français à
l'évidence le système de prise de
rendez-vous mérite d'être vu d'urgence
pour les postes concerné autre urgence
je veux vous parler de nos consules
honoraires qui exercent leurs fonction à
titre B vol ils sont un maillon
essentiel de notre réseau consulaire
dont le rôle doit être revu pour
l'adapter aux besoins d'aujourd'hui la
prise en charge totale ou partielle de
leurs dépenses de fonctionnement doivent
être revalorisé de plus il est
indispensable de garantir leur
protection juridique et sanitaire par un
système d'assurance enfin dernier
dernier point concernant le programme
151 depuis mon arrivée au Sénat je
plaide pour que notre pays se fixe pour
objectif que tous les Français sachent
parler français chacun a pu voir à la
télévision des Français d'Israël qui ne
parlent pas notre langue je l'ai dis
souvent ici 80 % des enfants français
nés en Israël comme en Algérie
d'ailleurs ne parle pas français plus
des 2 tiers en Amérique latine il y a 2
semaines au Brésil à Sao Poulo la chef
de chancellerie m'a indiqué qu'il est
rare que nos compatriotes nés au Brésil
parlent français depuis 2014 j'ai déposé
régulièrement un amendement chèque
éducation pour que le programme 151
tiennent compte des 80 % des enfants
français l'étranger qui ne fréquentent
pas notre réseau d'enseignement
cette idée a été reprise dans le
programme d'Emmanuel Macron en 2022 et
baptisé passéducation je remercie
Olivier beschte qui a budgetté 1 million
d'euros pour créer ce pass éducation
langue française le ministre délégué a
décidé de confier cette mission au kned
je soutiens cette initiative abordons
enfin le programme 185 diplomatie
culturelle d'influence les effectifs de
la EFE ont progressé à la rentré de
moins d'1 % pour atteindre 392000 élèves
l'effectif global c'est est accru de
plus de 40000 enfants supplémentaires
depuis 2018 soit 10 % en 5 ans très loin
de l'objectif initial du président de la
République qui prévoit de doubler les
effectifs d'ici à 2030 en écoutant les
rapporteurs il faudrait mettre davantage
de moyens pour y parvenir nous
encloutissons pourtant déjà plus de 400
millions d'euros annuellement pour la
EFE 455 cette année alors que nous avons
tant d'autres priorités pour le 185 nous
entretenons un système de compétition
déloyal absurde qui favorise une poignée
d'ogd et une minorité d'élèves au
détriment des réseaux français privés
l'enseignement angloaxon à l'étranger
vient d'annoncer sa progression sur la
dernière décennie ils sont passés de 4,4
millions à 6,7 millions d'élèves il se
développe 30 fois plus vite que nous
sans argent public l'enseignement à
l'étranger est un marché tant que cette
évidence ne sera pas intégrée en France
et que la gouvernance de la EFE ne sera
pas revue nous sommes condamnés à
reculer je ne me résigne pas l'anef
association nationale des école
française à l'étranger que je préside a
modifié ses statuts hier elle s'ouvre
aux écoles françaises non homologuées
pour ne laisser personne à la porte afin
de contribuer à l'atteint de l'objectif
du président de la République sans
besoin d'argent public le groupe Union
centriste votera les crédits de la
mission action extérieure de l'État je
vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à Madame matildde Olivier
pour le groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire et pour une durée de 5
minutes vous avez la parole ma chère
collègue monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues nous
examinons ce jour les crédits alloués à
la mission action extérieure de l'État
pour la première fois depuis la remise
du rapport des états généraux de la
diplomatie alors oui nous nous
réjouissons que les moyens humains et
budgétaire soit revu à la hausse vous
nous parlez d'un réarmement de la
diplomatie française pourquoi pas mais
bon entre nous il était temps après 30
ans de désarmement mais la vraie
question c'est est-ce que le projet de
loi répond aux besoins de nos
compatriotes à l'étranger et de notre
administration la réponse est non
service consulaires bourses scolaires
aide social CFE réseau éducatif et
culturel tous les voyant voyants sont au
rouge en 15 ans le programme 151 a perdu
500 ETP et ce alors que le nombre
d'inscrits au registre progressait de 13
% sur la même période qu'il y a un
nombre croissant de Français et de
français non inscrits et que des
millions de Français de passagees à
l'étranger chaque année nécessitent
aussi parfois une assistance consulaire
au sein de notre administration centrale
et de notre réseau les services sont
saturés pour y répondre la création de
700 ETP sur 4 ans a été annoncée en
grande pompe mais certains projets
accaparent déjà l'essentiel des
créations au détriment des services en
souseffet effectif chronique et notoire
vous nous parlez de
réarmement dans le projet annuel de
performance on parle de de la création
de
ETP dans le réseau d'ailleurs parmi ces
h postes combien sont des postes d'agent
titulaire de c'est quand même peu pour
réarmer nous remarquons la création du
Centre de soutien consulaire qui
permettra de disposer de missionnaires
de renfort en plus grand nombre mais ce
dont l'administration a besoin c'est
d'agents titulaires affectés sur des
postes de façon durable et non de
mission ponctuelles de quelques semaines
d'un pays à l'autre madame la ministre
qu'allez-vous dire à nos ressortissants
les plus fragiles cette année les
crédits alloués aux aides sociales sont
exactement les mêmes qu'en 2023 est-ce
que la situation économique encore
dégradée la persistance de l'inflation
ou le nombre d'allocataires en hausse
n'imposait pas une revalorisation
Argentine Égypte Liban Turquie dans de N
nombreux pays les besoins sont criants
et pour des économies de bout
dechandelle des centaines de personnes
sont laissées dans la précarité et la
pauvreté et puis la EFE et les bourses
scolaires cette année encore vous allez
demander aux parents qui ont des enfants
boursiers inscrits dans le réseau
d'enseignement français de contribuer
davantage en relevant la CPS de 2 à 7
points pour compenser l'insuffisance de
la
dotation cette année encore l'enveloppe
des bourses ne permettra pas de répondre
aux besoins en 2023 des déjà le p151
sous-doté a obligé le gouvernement vous
le savez à débloquer des moyens
supplémentaires conséquents en 2024 la
EFE sera pour la première fois dépourvue
de la fameuse soute qui lui permettait
de procéder aux ajustements nécessaires
pour palier le manque de crédit la
dotation de 118 millions envisagé pour
2024 ne couvrira même pas les effets de
l'inflation elle ne couvrira pas non
plus le taux de change défavorable ou la
hausse des frais d'collage nous ne voy
ons pas comment il sera possible dans
ces conditions de répondre aux demandes
de Bours
Scola la subvention pour charge de
service publics accordé à la EFE
parlons-en elle est équivalente à la
subvention prévue dans la loi de
finances de 2012 alors quit de la
chimère du doublement du nombre d'élèves
dans le réseau d'ici 2030 encore une
fois on observe des annonces répétées du
président de la République depuis 2019
mais cela ne se traduit pas dans les
faits la EFE reste en plus toujours
empêché de procéder aux investissements
immobiliers ou à la rénovation de ces
bâtiments pour répondre aux engagements
pris par l'État nous sommes aussi face à
un parc immobilier vieillissant parfois
vétuste et déjà soumis dans de nombreux
pays aux conséquences du changement
climatique et face à ces défis la
politique de rénovation thermique de
notre parc immobilier manque d'ambition
il en va de l'image de la France il en
va de l'attractivité dans le réseau
culturel et d'enseignement français des
conditions de travail des agents et de
l'accueil de nos ressortissants
d'ailleurs en parlant de notre r réseau
de opération culturelles et de nos
opérateurs ici aussi il est temps de
mettre nos ambitions en adéquation avec
nos moyens on ne peut pas accepter que
celui-ci deviennent de plus en plus
dépendants aux ressources privées ou
extérieures à la dotation de l'État pour
couvrir ses
besoins les moyens ne sont pas à la
hauteur des enjeux nous écologistes
attendons une prévision pluriannuelle
des moyens adapté pas d'effet d'annonce
pas de saopoudrage surtout lorsque les
engagements ne sont pas tenus à moins
d'engagements supplémentaires
significatifs du gouvernement le le
groupe écologiste ne votera pas les
crédits de cette mission nous invitons
le le gouvernement à réexaminer les
besoins et notamment ceux des Françaises
et Français établis hors de France et de
notre réseau
consulaire merci chers
collègues la parole est maintenant à
Madame Michelle grehum pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste kanaki et pour une durée de 5
minutes vous avez la parole ma cher
collègue monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues dans une
période où les guerres frappent dans
l'Est de l'Europe au Caucase au Soudan
sans oublier le conflit en Israël
Palestine qui connaît une escalade
meurtrière dramatique depuis 2 mois il
me paraît être une évidence dans un tel
contexte d'affirmer avec gravité que la
France se doit de disposer une action
extérieure forte d'une politique
ambitieuse en matière de solidarité
internationale ainsi que d'un réseau
diplomatique à la hauteur de ses
ambitions naturellement nous accueillons
favorablement le augmentation des
crédits alloués à la mission action
extérieure de l'État ainsi que la hausse
des effectifs avec 146 équivalents temps
plat supplémentairire toutefois nous
n'oublions pas que celle-ci intervient
après des années de coupe budgétaire
particulièrement virulente d'ailleurs en
s'y penchant de plus près nous nous
rendons compte que cette hausse
d'effectif repose en grande partie sur
l'utilisation de contrats locaux et non
de contrats français au salaires souvent
très FAI il me semble urgent que le qu
d'orsé garantisse aux agents en poste à
l'étranger des conditions correctes de
rémunération passer ses considération
budgétaire il me semble-il de rappeler
la priorité de ce budget tel que figure
à la page 8 du bleu budgétaire à savoir
la sécurité et la stabilité par la
préservation de la paix et le règlement
des crises à l'extérieur de nos
frontières car sinon comparons les 3
mliards 5 d'euros consacrés à la
diplomatie au 47,2 milliards d'euros du
budget des armées soit 13,5 fois moins
il apparaît évident que les ambitions de
l'exécutif sont toutes autres cette
asymétrie budgétaire relève à nos yeux
d'une lecture faussée des enjeux
géostratégiques d'aujourd'hui dans un
monde ampli d'insécurité globale
alimentaire sanitaire migratoire sociale
et énergétique se contenter de préparer
la guerre constitue une erreur grave
erreur grave et l de conséquence face à
laampérieuse nécessité d'élaborer une
stratégie de sécurité humaine globale
dont la diplomatie devrait être la pièce
maîtresse cette stratégie diplomatique
aucieuse au service de la paix notre
pays s'en éloigne un peu plus chaque
jour le cas du conflit colonial en
Palestine est frappant et marque une
singulière dérive française le décalage
entre l'image de la position française
qui persistait encore dans les pays
arabes et la réaction présidentielle au
conflit à Gaza a ainsi profondément
choqué faute aussi peut-être aux
improvisations du président avec
notamment sa proposition d'une coalition
internationale visant à éradiquer le
Hamas le journal Libération nous apprend
que celle-ci aurait été soufflée par
Bernard Henri Lévi le même qui a suggéré
12 ans plus tôt président Sarkozi de
bombarder la Libye où depuis règne la
fin et le chaos le malaise a gagné
jusqu'au rang de notre appareil
diplomatique puisqueune dizaine de
diplomates vous ont exprimé leur
incompréhension face aux position du
président sur la situation dramatique en
cours au Moyen-Orient face à tant
d'acharnement des promoteurs de guerre
la France serait se serait
particulièrement singularisé en lançant
une initiative diplomatique inédite pour
obtenir un cessc feu immédiat et
relancer un processus de paix seulement
notre diplomatie souffre d'un peu de
poids de mesure qui rend la voie de
notre pays au sein des instances
internationales inaudibles à ce même à
ce même
madame le la ministre vous demandiez il
y a peu il y a un peu plus d'un an et
vous aviez raison le retrait des troupes
russes d'ucraine vous semblez beaucoup
plus réservé aujourd'hui à vous exprimer
de la même façon s'agissant du retrait
des troupes israéliennes de Gaza ou des
colons israéliens en S Jordanie or le
droit international doit être respecté
partout pourquoi ces hésitations parce
que cette faillite morale et à ce cet
échec politique qui caractérise la
position française
sur la situation en cours au
Moyen-Orient s'ajoute le poids d'une
culture coloniale dont notre politique
étrangère a du mal à se défaire cette
même culture qui en Afrique à coup
d'intervention militaire ou encore par
notre domination monétaire a conduit à
fiasco politique et diplomatique au
Sahel il faut changer de logiciel sans
quoi nous ne parviendrons jamais à
construire quoi que ce soit de sérieux
en matière de sécurité collective sortir
du deux poids de mesures en matière de
de respect du droit international se
détacher d'une logique binaire de bloc
de dans notre vision du monde afin de
privilégier les solution politique au
conflits mais aussi d'en éradiquer les
racines cela passe également par la
promotion d'un nouvel ordre économique
par une transition climatique à la
hauteur des enjeux par une aide publique
au développement juste et ambitieuse par
le respect des droits des femmes par
l'éradication de la FA nous nous
abstiendrons sur ce budget car nous
jugeons que les crédits apportés sont
bien trop faible ce budget aurait dû
constituer la priorité stratégique de
notre politique de sécurité mondiale
merci merci ma cher collègue la parole
est maintenant à Monsieur André guyol
pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen et pour
une durée de 5
minutes vous avez la parole mon cher
collègue merci président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues les
discussions sur les crédits de la
mission Action action extérieure de
l'État nous invitent à la plus grande
solennité et à une certaine gravité face
aux crises diplomatiques et sécuritaires
qui
s'enchaîne guerre de conquête conf gelé
guerre de défense la liste des régions
en proid à des tensions s'allonge au fil
du temps près de nous en Ukraine dans le
haut Caraba et au ProcheOrient cet
accroissement des violences par les
armes symbolise-t-il un essoufflement de
de la diplomatie internationale
oui bien sûr car ces instruments de
règlement des conflits internationaux
semblent marquer le pas pour autant la
diplomatie doit redevenir la première
boussole du maintien de la paix c'est je
pense la volonté de la France comme en
témoigne madame la ministre votre appel
conjoint avec le ministre des armées en
faveur d'une paix durable entre Israël
et le Hamas au-delà de l'importance de
la voix de la France il nous faut
maintenir les moyens de l'action
extérieure dans les luttes d'influence
qui se jouent au sein de l'ordre
international notre pays doit maintenir
son rang c'est en tout cas ce qui est
recommandé par les États généraux de la
diplomatie qui plaide pour davantage de
moyens matériels et humains nos
collègues rapporteurs l'ont souligné les
crédits de la mission vont dans le bon
sens puisque ce sont 390 millions
d'euros supplémentaires qui seront
mobilisés en 2024 soit une hausse de 6 %
par rapport à 2023 une première étape
dans la promesse de hausse de 20 % sur
les 4 années à venir ces crédits
permettront de monter des effectifs dont
nous attendons toutefois des réponses
quant à leur répartition par ailleurs la
restauration de notre crédibilité
internationale nécessite aussi la
consolidation de nos contribution au
profit des organisations internationales
et européenne la France tient ses
engagements notamment ceux de Paris appr
pris au sommet de Madrid en 2022 à
l'égard de l'OTAN d'une part et ceux qui
facilitent la démarche européenne pour
la paix d'autre part on s'en réjouit
parce que le qu d'orsé ne doit pas être
uniquement le ministère des crises j'en
viens à notre réseau d'influence
l'affaiblissement des institutions
internationale que j'évoqué au début de
mon propos nous oblige à repenser
l'utilisation des canaux diplomatiques
classiques pour encourager une stratégie
d'influence constructive le renforcement
de notre réseau culturel amorce cette
mutation la répartition des crédits du
programme diplomatie culturelle et
d'influence est rassurante le
renforcement très significatif des
crédits profita aux différents
opérateurs ainsi qu'aux Alliances
françaises mon groupe attaché aux
valeurs que peut porter la francophonie
se réjouit du soutien accru à
l'enseignement du français à l'étranger
nous saluons les ressources mises à
disposition de la EFE dans un contexte
de compétition internationale accru il
faut une politique attractivité
ambitieuse cependant s'agissant de
l'enseignement du français à l'étranger
si l'offre des moyens n'est pas suivi
d'une progression conséquente des
effectifs quels sont les leviers d'
davantage d'élèves en revanche la
revalorisation à hauteur de 6 millions
d'euros de crédit alloués aux bourses
pour les étudiants étrangers va dans le
bon sens enfin quelques mots sur
certaines difficultés vécues par nos
concitoyens à l'étranger au auxquel il
faudra répondre je pense que notre ami
Cadic l'a soulevé je pense au délai
d'attente des services consulaires pour
la délivrance de visa cours séjour qui
continue à s'accroître la baisse des
moyens humains accordés au traitement
des visas dans les programmes concerné
est inquiétante nous au aimé nous
aurions aimé que le plafond d'emploi de
chaque poste soit revu à la hausse
au-delà de la question du confort pour
nos administrés il en va aussi de la
crédibilité de la France au terme de ces
quelques observations mes chers
collègues nous voterons ce budget
globalement volontariste du ministère de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères dans
le droitfil des états généraux de la
diplomatie il marque la genèse d'un
changement de paradigme une évolution
que le RDSE accueille avec satisfaction
je vous remercie
merci mon cher collègue la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur jean-badis Lemoine
pour le groupe du Rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et indépendants
et pour une durée de 7 minutes vous avez
la parole mon cher collègue merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre madame monsieur le les
rapporteurs spéciaux chers collègues bon
donc nous voici réunis pour évoquer les
crédits dédiés à notre action extérieur
et et si les chiffres peuvent parfois
nous diviser puisque la loi de finance
c'est un acte éminemment politique celui
par lequel la nation affecte les
ressources aux différentes politiques
publiques nul doute que la fierté et
l'ambition que nous nourrissons pour la
France dans le monde nous rassemble et
c'est heureux et donc en tant que
parlementaire notre rôle de vigil madame
la ministre est de nous assurer que vous
avez les moyens d'agir pour maintenir la
singularité française parmi les grandes
puissances dans le concer des nations
pour préserver renforcer l'exceptionnel
réseau diplomatique et consulaire qui
est le nôtre et puis pour conforter le
lien qui est aussi fort qu'unique avec
les Français établirs de France qui
participent an à notre rayonnement bref
s'assurer que la maison France a les
moyens de faire face dans un contexte où
on le voit la multiplication de régimes
politiques qui se rédisent qui mettent
au défi le multilatéralisme et qui
mettent à mal parfois institutions et
normes internationales et donc dans ce
contexte nous devons continuellement
réinterroger notre action notre façon de
faire pour l'adapter à cette nouvelle
donne nouvelle donne avec de nouvelles
polarisations de nouveaux acteurs qui
émergent bruyamment sur la scène
internationale avec des coalitions plus
mouvantes et volatiles que jamais
et puis nouvelle donne aussi avec des
conflits gelés ou latant qui sont
réactivés de l'Ukraine au carabach du
Yémen à Gaza Israël avec la crainte de
contagion bien sûr et c'est dans ce
contexte que le Président de la
République a souhaité les états généraux
de la diplomatie un exercice assez
inédit dans l'histoire du quederset pour
poser les bases de ce réarmement qui a
été si souvent évoqué dans les
précédentes interventions avec des
objectifs très concrets des moyens de
l'adaptation mieux valoriser les
carrières mieux sécuriser et mieux
influencé je salue d'ailleurs le le
travail conduit par Jérôme bonafon et
puis les conclusions fortes tirées par
le Président de la République lui-même
lors de son discours le 16 mars 2023 6
mois plus tard et bien nous y voilà vous
présenter un budget pour l'année 2024
qui est un jalon fort dans ce chemin qui
nous mène jusqu'à 2027 tous les
rapporteurs d'ailleurs spéciaux pour
avis ont salué et bien ce réengagement à
la fois budgétaire et humain avec des
moyens qui atteignent 3,5 milliards
d'euros soit une une augmentation de 6 %
une fois corrigé l'effet de l'inflation
et donc cela vient mettre justement je
pense un terme à des interrogations
diffuses mais bien réelles depuis des
décennies au sein du kedorset puisque il
y avait ce sentiment d'une déprise
sentiment qui était réel souvenons-nous
déjà en 2003 des agents du ministère
venaient manifester devant le Sénat et
il y avait depuis depuis des décennies
cette baisse d'effectif
à laquelle un coup d'arrêt a été mis
depuis 2 ans et maintenant avec une
augmentation qui est significative et
donc 20 ans plus tard nous y sommes avec
ces crédits abondés avec les 700 ETP qui
vont être créés et dont une traduction
se fait dans le budget avec 165 ETP dès
l'année prochaine et puis ce budget 2024
c'est un budget qui est toujours plus au
service de nos compatriotes Fran de
l'étranger avec un programme
151 qui est marqué par une hausse
significative de 17 % soit plus 24
millions d'euros c'est une offre de
service qui continue à s'étoffer pour
faciliter la vie de nos compatriotes
établis hors de France je pense à la
poursuite du déploiement de France
consulaire ce petit trésor et cette
plateforme si utile qui permet justement
d'apporter une réponse immédiate aux
Français de par le monde nous allons
atteindre en 2025 la couverture de 4 17
% des Français de l'étranger euh et
également avec dans ce budget des
éléments pour la mise en œuvre du
programme qu'avait présenté le président
de la République pour nos compatriotes
établieurs de France nous l'avons dit
nous le faisons le passe éducation
langue française qui a été évoqué par
Olivier cadick la dématérialisation du
renouvellement des passe-eport et je
peux vous dire que c'est pas une mince à
faaire parce que il y avait un certain
nombre de freins dans d'autres parties
de l'État euh l'expérimentation va enfin
se mettre en place euh avec le Portugal
et et et le Canada avant on espère la
généralisation et puis euh également euh
un amendement euh je tiens à évoquer un
amendement Cigné avec les collègues le
gleu euh gantard et et Boyer pour euh
euh abonder effectivement euh les
crédits de la CFE la caisse des
franceces à de l'étranger au titre de la
catégorie D afin de doubler euh
effectivement l'effort de l'État et
enfin sur euh C sujets des Français de
l'étranger je crois que il faut si tous
les ministres doivent être des ministres
des Français de l'étranger et chacun
veiller à ce que leur politique publique
prennent en compte les Français établir
de France que le ministère des Affaires
étrangères que la DFAE soit ce pilote
interministériel et puisse avoir cette
vision globale au-delà du consulaire
pour vraiment s'assurer et bien que la
vie de nos compatriotes est prise en
compte sous tous ces aspects parce que
voilà il faut souvent souvent euh lever
un certain nombre de freins ici et là
euh au niveau des services de l'État et
puis ce budget 2024 c'est celui aussi
qui conforte qui renforce notre
diplomatie culturelle d'influence ça a
été dit le programme 185 + 62 millions
d'euros moi je me réjouis qu'il est ce
fond d'aide aux alliances françaises on
sait que c'est un tissu qui est à la
fois très dense mais aussi qui souvent
repose sur quelques personnes et qui
peut être mis à mal le covid hélas étant
passé par là peut mettre à mal les les
modèles de ces établissements ces
institut
et donc ce fond de soutien est bienvenu
de la même façon et bien que nous devons
un appui renforcé au réseau de
l'enseignement français à l'étranger
dans toutes ses composantes nous avons
naturellement éminent de respect pour
les EGD mais je veux lancer ici à cette
tribune aussi comment dire un appel pour
aider les partenaires Samantha casbonne
notre collègue justement des sénatrice
français des Français établieurs de
France vous AZ écrit il y a quelques
jours pour que la MLF la Mission laïque
française puisse recevoir un soutien
additionnel de l'ordre de 3 million
d'euros au moins elle représente 1/5e
des établissements dans le monde et nous
avons besoin voilà de ces acteurs
renforcés pour atteindre l'objectif
effectivement de doublement des
effectifs à l'échéance 2030 et puis le
sujet immobilier qui demeure préignant
et sur lequel effectivement nous
attendons que les arrêtés soi pris et
s'il y a besoin au moment de changer la
loi organique et bien écoutez chers amis
chers collègues pardon prenons
responsabilité initions une proposition
de loi organique et on règlera le
problème si Bery ne veut pas le régler
voilà j'en viens à la fin et à ma
conclusion monsieur le Président pour
vous dire vous l'avez compris que le
groupe RDPI votera non seulement avec
satisfaction chers collègues du RSE mais
avec enthousiasme les crédits de la
mission de l'action extérieure de l'État
voilà puisque c'est l'anné 1 de cette
politique de réarmement de la diplomatie
française pour conserver un statut de
puissance à part et à part entière je
vous remercie merci Monsieur le Ministre
la parole est à Madame Hélène conou
Mouret pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain et pour une
durée de 9
minutesèg
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues la France
possède une empreinte territoriale dans
le monde entier grâce à un ensemble de
réseaux diplomatiques consulair éducatif
culturel et économique qu'elle a bâti au
fil du temps héritage que nous avons le
devoir de consolider ce maillage et
cette expérience confè à notre pays un
avantage dont peu dispose celui d'être
en mesure de déployer une politique
complète et coordonnée au service de nos
intérêts or si nous nous réjouissons de
la hausse des moyens humains et
financiers pour 2024 de nombreuses
interrogations subsistent sur la manière
dont sera assuré le renforcement de la
place de la France don le concer des
nations ainsi que sa capacité à agir en
revenant sur les différents programmes
qui composent la mission j'évoquerai les
améliorations que notre groupe juge
indispensa pour donner corps à cette
ambition de transformation de notre
action
diplomatique tout d'abord notre réseau
consulaire est le premier contact qui
donne accès à nos services publics à nos
ressortissants et à tous les étrangers
qui ont un lien avec la France après
avoir été le parent pauvre de
l'augmentation du budget du ministère en
2023 le programme bénéficiera d'une
hausse de 17 % cette année qui permet un
premier
rattrapage ces crédits permettront
notamment d'approfondir la modernisation
de l'administration consulaire et
d'achever le déploiement du service
France consulaire cette plateforme de
réponse aux appels des usagers ne
saurait néanmoins être considérée comme
un sub situe à l'accueil physique seul
contact possible pour nombreux d'entre
eux bien que nous puissions nous réjouir
que ces effectifs connaissent enfin une
augmentation la création de 20 ETP reste
en desessà des besoins notamment pour
les services d'état civil et des visas
en effet le délai de traitement des
dossiers ne cesse de s'allonger du fait
de la recrudaescence des demandes post
pandémie de la petite taille des équipes
mais aussi de la prolifération
d'officines privées qui bloquent des
crédits de rendez-vous disponibles pour
les revendre à des ager désespéré
d'obtenir un rendez-vous cette crise des
visas engendre une détérioration des
conditions de travail des agents et une
insatisfaction grandissante des
demandeurs qui portent atteinte à
l'image de la France à
l'étranger l'envoi d'agent de renfort
pour absorber le surplu d'activité et
palier le manque d'effectifs a permis de
redire les délais d'attente mais ne
représente en aucun cas une solution
pérenne c'est la raison pour laquelle
mon groupe proposera d'accélérer les
créations de postes au sein du réseau
conçu ire nous tenterons également de
combler trois lacunes de ce budget d'une
part le montant alloué aux aides
sociales est simplement reconduit alors
même que l'inflation mondiale et la
déval dévalorisation du cours de l'euro
sur lequel reposent les allocations
perdurent dans de nombreux pays au
regard des besoins observés sur le
terrain mon groupe proposera le
réhaussement de cette enveloppe d'autre
part ce qui est présenté comme une
augmentation significative de 13,6
millions d'euros des crédits àoués aux
bourses scolaires estt on fait un
trompelœil en effet en tenant compte du
dégel de la réserve de l'ordre de 5 %
l'enveloppe de 118 millions d'euros se
révèle inférieure à celle de l'année
dernière alors qu'elle était déjà
insuffisante mon groupe fera plusieurs
propositions pour permettre à toutes les
familles françaises de continuer à
scolariser leurs enfants malgré la
hausse des frais d'écollage par ailleurs
des interrogations subsistent sur les
modalités d'exécution du passe éducation
nouvellement doté d'un million d'euros
quels seront madame la ministre les pays
retenus pour l'expérimentation et les
prestataires
éligibles enfin le soutien à la Caisse
des Français de l'étranger unique caisse
de sécurité sociale pour les
nonrésidents est un impensé de ce budget
elle se retrouve seule pour assurer la
mission de service public qui lui a été
confiée par l'État puisque son concours
au financement de la catégorie aid est
passé de 50 % à 10 %. compte tenu des
difficultés financière que rencontre cet
organisme essentiel à des milliers de
nos compatriotes en particulier hors de
l'Union européenne mon groupe demandera
un réengagement fort de la part de
l'État en faveur de la CFE le deuxème
axe repose sur notre réseau diplomatique
dont l'augmentation du budget à hauteur
de 8,7 % et des effectifs avec 110 ETP
supplémentaires à pour ambition de
compenser les économies réalisées
précédemment ces moyens serviront à une
remise à niveau du réseau et c'est
heureux que nous sollicitons chaque
année lors du débat budgétaire nous
serons toutefois vigilants sur deux
points premère prèrement si le Centre de
Crise du ministère verra son budget
augmenté de 450000 € qui lui permettront
de recruter environ 5 TP nous observons
une multiplication et une
intensification des crises dans
lesquelles son intervention est cruciale
pour protéger nos ressortissants nous
espérons simplement que ces moyens
seront suffisants pour faire face aux
crises à venir deuxièmement la
coopération en matière de sécurité de
défense qui passe essentiellement par la
formation grâce à l'envoi de coopérants
issus des armées de la la gendarmerie de
la police et des douanes semble
sous-estimé pourtant j'ai observé à
Djibouti en Mauritanie que la demande de
coopération avec la France qui dispose
d'un réel savoir-faire et toujours forte
là encore nous espérons que vos
estimations permettront d'atteindre
l'objectif d'accroître l'offre de
formation de 40
%. pour finir la diplomatie culturelle
et d'influence est le 3oè pilier de
cette ambition il détermine notre
capacité à faire vivre le modèle
français et européen que nous défendons
dans dans un monde où nos compétiteurs
tentent d'imposer parout les canaux
sinon par la force leur propre vision du
monde la France possède des atouts
majeurs qu'elle doit entretenir elle
dispose d'abord du premier réseau
culturel au monde nos alliances et nos
instituts français bénéficieront d'un
soutien dont je ne peux que me réjouir
pour l'avoir réclamé chaque année avec
le même amendement satisfait cette année
elle dispose aussi du premier réseau
éducatif au monde grâce à son maillage
d'établissement d'enseignement français
toutefois l'ambition de notre pays de
doubler le nombre d'élèves à l'horizon
de 2030 ne s'accompagne toujours pas des
moyens à la hauteur de l'objectif comme
cela a été rappelé par certains orateurs
précédents l'augmentation de 8 million
d'euros de la subvention pour charge de
service public de l'Agence pour
l'enseignement français à l'étranger ne
se traduira pas en réalité par un
accroissement de ces moyens pour
absorber les
surcûts liés à la réforme du statut des
personnel détaché pour 15 millions
d'euros à la hausse du point d'indice
pour 7 millions d'euros et aux
conséquences de l'inflation pour 7,6
million d'euros l'agence sera contrainte
d'augmenter les contributions des
établissements ce qui se traduira
mécaniquement par une hausse des droits
de scolarité pour les familles par
ailleurs la question du financement des
projets immobiliers des établissements
en gestion directe estimé à près de 200
millions d'euros n'est toujours pas
résolu ce qui entrave le développement
du réseau et nuit
fortement à l'attractivité de notre
offre éducative il devient donc urgent
d'apporter une solution pérenne telle
que l'inscription d'une subvention pour
charge d'investissement au sein du
programme dès la prochaine loi de
financeces je veux d'ailleurs exprimer
notre satisfaction même si elle est
relative car nous ne souhaitons pas
qu'on y trouve prétexte au rejet de
certains de nos amendements sur le
maintien de l'article 50A qui prévoit la
remise d'un rapport gouvernemental sur
les capacités d'emprunt de l'agence
la France jouit aussi d'une forte
attractivité en matière d'enseignement
supérieur mise au défi par des pays qui
ont parfaitement compris que les
étudiants étrangers sont leurs meilleurs
ambassadeurs lors de leur retour dans
leur pays d'origine et qui développent
des stratégies offensives pour les
attirer alors que la France décroche
l'augmentation de 6 millions d'euros de
l'enveloppe allouée aux bourses d'études
est nécessaire mais sera-t-elle
suffisante pour atteindre l'objectif de
doublement de ces bourses à l'horizon
2030 fixé dans le cadre de la stratégie
bienvenue en France enfin la situation
financière de Campus France en déficit
de 1,7 million d'euros représente un
angle mort de ce budget que mon groupe
tentera de combler en conclusion alors
que nous pourrions nous réjouir que le
PLF 2024 propose une augmentation
conséquente des crédits de la mission
action extérieure de l'État la
rapporteur spéciale de la mission
défendra un amendement visant à réduire
ses crédits de 30 millions ur au regard
de l'ensemble des considérations que je
viens de développer devant vous
l'adoption de cet amendement par notre
assemblée conduirait notre groupe à
s'abstenir sur les crédits de cette
mission et donnera un avis favorable
s'il était rejeté je vous remercie merci
Madame la Ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Terry men pour le groupe les
républicains et pour une durée de 8
minutes
vous avez la parole mon cher
collègue monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues avec la fin
de la guerre froide le monde a connu
durant une trentaine d'années une
parenthèse géopolitique au cours de
cette période le relatif apaisement de
l'ordre international assis sur le
primat américain mais aussi sur une
certaine prévalence du droit du
multilatéralisme et du Commerce a pu
donner à certains l'illusion d'une
marche continue vers la paix et la
stabilité l'invasion de l'Ukraine fut
une brutale prise de conscience pour
l'Europe et la France le révélateur
d'une nouvelle ère placée sous le signe
de l'incertitude de la polarisation de
la
confrontation dans celle-ci les
impérialisme se réveill les puissances
régionales s'affirment les recours à la
force se multiplient et accélère
l'effacement la la
marginalisation des enceintes
internationales en toile de fond
certains régimes autoritaires tentent de
ressusciter à leur profit une logique de
bloc destinée à saperer l'influence
occidentale mais en cherchant à
provoquer un divorce entre ce qu'elles
appellent l'Occident collectif et le Sud
global c'est en fait une nouvelle
fragmentation du monde que ces
puissances font le choix d'attiser et
c'est dans cet inquiétant climat global
qu'en Arménie au Proche Orient ou en
République démocratique du Congo des
conflits naissent ou se réactivent qu'au
Sahel ou en Ukraine certains s'enlisent
qu'en mer de Chine méridionale dans le
détroit de Taïwan et dans le Golfe de
Guinée d'autres semblent en
gestation cette nouvelle donne a incité
les Européens à réinvestir d'urgence
l'outil militaire qu'ils avaient
délaissé c'est bien fondamental mais ce
n'est pas suffisant car s'il est indice
pensable de se préparer à l'éventualité
de la guerre il est tout aussi
nécessaire de se donner les moyens d'en
éloigner le spectre en d'autres termes
il est évident que dans le monde tel
qu'il se dessine la diplomatie sera
essentielle elle le sera d'autant plus
pour un pays comme le nôtre qui jouit
d'un statut international particulier
qui entant jouer dans le monde un rôle
singulier hors depuis plusieurs années
son influence décroit sur la scène
internationale à présent c'est son image
qui est battu en brèche et pas seulement
sur le continent
africain alors pour tenir son rang de
puissance et continuer à peser sur le
cours du monde pour rester en capacité
d'y défendre ses intérêts comme ses
valeurs la France aura besoin d'une
diplomatie
forte souignons aussi que nos diplomates
et je veux ici leur rendre hommage un
hommage
particulier joue un rôle crucial lorsque
dans des situations de crise nos
compatriotes établis à l'étranger sont
menacés que ce soit en Afghanistan en
Ukraine au Soudan au Niger ou au proche-
Orient ils ont tenu ces dernières années
au côté de nos militaires une place
centrale dans les remarquables
opérations d'évacuation qui ont permis
la mise en sécurité de nos
ressortissants il mérite donc des moyens
à la hauteur de la tâche qui leur
incombe or la somnolence stratégique qui
a frappé les États européens ces
dernières décennies s'est aussi
accompagné d'une certaine forme
d'indolence diplomatique
cette tendance a été particulièrement
marquée dans notre pays car s'il
conserve l'un des réseaux diplomatiques
les plus étoffés les plus compétent du
monde n'oublions pas qu'en 30 ans le
budget du ministère des Affaires
étrangères a régressé de manière
constante et que ces effectifs ont été
réduits de moitié or ces années de
profonde après pardon après ces
profondes ces années de profonde érosion
la tendance semble désormais s'inverser
ainsi après avoir progressé de 160
million d'euros en 2023 les crédits de
la mission action extérieure de l'État
connaîtront une nouvelle hausse
substantielle de 9 % en 2024 quant aux
effectifs du Cadoret ils bénéficieront
cela a été dit précédemment de 165
nouveaux emplois temp en plein après la
après la création nette de 106 postes
décidés l'année
dernière bien sûr nous ne sommes pas
encore au réarmement de notre diplomatie
annoncé par le président de la
République cela prendra du temps et
dépendra aussi de notre action globale
sur nos finances publiques dont l'état
déplorable ne permet pas de dégager des
marges de manœuvre budgétaire au niveau
que nous souhaiterions en outre notre
capacité à renouveler et à renforcer
notre politique étrangère ne sera pas
seulement fonction de nouveaux moyens
elle découlera aussi de la manière dont
ceux-ci seront employés or la plupart
des lignes budgétaires de la mission
augmentant dans des proportions
relativement homogènes les priorités
politiques qui se dégagent de ce projet
de loi de finance reste difficile à
cerner quant à l'affectation des
ressources additionnelles financières ou
humaines ell reste parfois relativement
obscure naturellement je salue certains
des axes mis en avant lors de la
présentation du budget 2024 je pense par
exemple au moyens supplémentaires
destinés à notre réseau consulaire qui a
tant souffert au cours des dernières
années je pense également au
renforcement des capacités d'analyse et
de communication en particulier dans nos
postes en Afrique et dans
l'Indo-Pacifique à l'heure de la lutte
informationnelle et de la montée du
sentiment anti-fançais en Afrique il
s'agit en effet d'un levier essentiel
pour restaurer et renforcer l'influence
de notre
pays mais il faut bien avouer que
budgétairement parlant peu d'éléments
ressortent de manière particulièrement
saillante or face à ce que nos
rapporteurs spéciaux ont identifié à
juste titre comme comme un risque de
saupoudrage des moyens supplémentaires
octroyés à notre diplomatie sans doute
serait-il plus efficace de concentrer
nos effort sur un nombre restreint
d'objectifs clairement
identifiés à cet égard permettez-moi de
souligner que c'est au même effort de
clarté et de lisibilité que le chef de
l'État gagnerait à s'astreindre dans
dans l'expression de la stratégie
diplomatique française en effet qu'il
s'agisse de la conduite de notre
politique africaine plus récemment des
positions exprimées sur Taïwan
ou le conflit du ProcheOrient les
décisions contradictoires les
revirements les déclarations dictées par
l'improvisation du moment se sont
multiplié mettant à l'épreuve la la
crédibilité diplomatique de la France il
est vrai que le métier de diplomate est
complexe qu'il est le fruit d'un long
apprentissage or comme le rappelait
jéromeme bonafond rapporteur des états
généraux de la diplomatie je cite la
disparition des corps diplomatiques a
été vécu comme la négation d'un métier
dans sa
spécificité fin de
citation malgré la tenue de ces états
généraux malgré les annonces sur les
crédits supplémentaires dégagés jusqu'en
2027 ce sentiment de malaise ne s'est
pas dissipé et les craintes nées de la
réforme voulu par le Président de la
République n'ont pas toutes été levé le
rapport issu de ce large exercice de
consultation contient néanmoins un
certain nombre de préconisations sur
l'avenir des carrières diplomatiques on
ne peut que souhaiter que leur mise en
œuvre permettra d'aplanir certaines
difficultés et qu'elle contribuera à
apaiser en partie le trouble ressenti
par nombre de ces grands serviteurs de
l'État que sont les diplomates madame la
ministre mes chers collègues au bénéfice
de ces observations le groupe les
républicains votera les crédits de la
mission action extérieure de l'État je
vous remercie merci mon cher
collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Vincent louau
pour le groupe les indépendants et pour
une durée de 5 minutes vous avez la
parole mon cher collègue monsieur le
Président mes chers
collègues madame la ministre l'agression
russe n'est pas terminée et la guerre
ravage toujours l'Ukraine les
perspectives de paix sont difficiles à
entrevoir l'Europe n'est pas la seule
région du monde à être le théâtre des de
conflits armés une semaine avant
l'attaque du Hamas le conseil à la
sécurité Joe Biden déclaré que le
Moyen-Orient était plus apaisé qu'au
cours des deux derniers des deux
dernières décennies précédente les
événements l'ont hélas fait mentir là
encore la paix semble s'éloigner le
Sahel a connu une succession de coups
d'État appuyé par la Russie ils font
craindre le pire pour la sécurité de la
région en Asie les États-Unis restent
déterminés à contenir les véléité
d'expansion chinoise notamment autour de
Taïwan s'ajoute à cela les tirs de et
les lancements de satellit de la Corée
du Nord qui continue de perturber la
zone le risque d'embrasement de la
région est élevé tout ceci nous conduit
à nous interroger le regain de tension
et la course aux armements sont-ils le
corollaire d'un monde multipolaire si
nous voulons éviter le piège de tu
tudine le piège des postures agressives
de l'escalad et des catastrophes il est
indispensable de renforcer nos capacités
de dialogue et de négociation N nous
nous félicitons donc que le gouvernement
a consenti cette année à une hausse
significative du budget consacré à
l'action extérieure de l'État cette
hausse sera notamment employée à
sécuriser nos emprises dans un monde
plus instable nous le devons aux femmes
et aux hommes qui porte la voix de la
France dans les régions les plus
reculées et les plus dangereuses du
monde depuis la réforme de la fonction
publique notre diplomatie était plongé
dans l'incertitude les États généraux
qui ne se sont achevés au début de cette
année ont permis de tracer c'est des
lignes claires la diplomatie est une
force dans laquelle nous devons investir
elle nous permet bien entendu de peser
sur les conflits en cours mais également
d'empêcher leur déclenchement au-delà de
cette gestion des crises nous souhaitons
que la diplomatie mette davantage en
valeur l'action de la
France les opinions publiques de
plusieurs pays du Sahel ont été la CBE
de campagne de désinformation savamament
mené par la Russie dégradant l'image de
la France la réalité de ces attaques ne
doit pas nous faire oublier la nécessité
de faire évoluer nos méthode de
communication nous devons entrer
pleinement dans la modernité si si ne n
voulons pas nous laisser distancer mieux
communiquer nous permettra aussi de
mieux coopérer la France se veut une
puissance d'équilibre elle a pour cela
besoin d'être intégré au sein de des
réseau d'alliances qui lui permettent de
peser nos contributions à cet égard sont
de véritables investissements le
développement de coopération dans le
domaine dans les domaines culturels et
scientifiques doit non se seulement nous
permettre d'entretenir nos compétences
et notre attractivité en ces matières
mais aussi plus largement se faire de
faire rayonner la France ses idées et
ses valeur l'enseignement français est à
cet égard fondamental cet enseignement
ne nous donne pas simplement une langue
en partage il s'agit
aussi un formidable vecteur pour nos
valeurs et notre mode de vie la liberté
bien sûr mais également l'égalité femme
homme ou encore le droit des peuples à
disposer d'eux-mêm dans un monde
multipolaire la France doit pouvoir
parler à tous et être capable de faire
entendre sa voix nous nous félicitons de
la hausse du budget consacré à la
diplomatie cette année à fortiori parce
que le Président de la République nous a
assuré qu'elle se poursuivrait dans les
années à venir avec des effectifs
renforcés et des moyens modernisés notre
diplomatie retrouve la place qui lui
revient le groupe des indépendants
votera donc en faveur de l'adoption de
ces crédits merci merci mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur Michel
logier
pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste et pour un temps de parole de
minutesz la parole mon cher
collègue monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues notre
commission a récemment conduit une
mission d'information sur l'expertise
patrimoniale française à l'étranger dont
nos collègues Joseph et Catherine min de
sa était rapporteur celle-ci démontre
que la France non seulement dispose de
formidables atouts mais jouit d'une
image d'excellence à l'international est
attendu sur toute une série de sujets il
faut donc considérer que l'action
extérieure de l'État dans toutes ses
dimensions est loin d'être un enjeu
subalterne surtout lorsqu'elle permet de
promouvoir les valeurs de nos
démocraties dans un monde toujours plus
menaçant hélas pour renforcer ce qu'est
notre diplomatie d'influence le rapport
plaide en premier lieu pour une
meilleure coordination des deux
ministères concernés culture et Affaires
étrangères maintenant à l'heure où a été
ouvert le centre de villercotré il faut
rappeler que la francophonie vecteur
important de promotion de la diversité
culturelle et linguistique porteur des
valeurs de démocratie reste aussi un
enjeu essentiel il faut donc en soutenir
les artisans à ce titre comme l'a fait
notre rapporteur Claude Kerne je tiens à
saluer le travail que font nos réseaux
de diplomatie culturelle et
d'enseignement français à l'étranger
s'adaptant continuellement au contexte
géopolitique on saluera que malgré les
conflits les missions se poursuivent du
mieux possible en Ukraine et au
ProcheOrient à ramala à Jérusalem Est et
Ouest à Bethléem on notera qu'en Israël
l'ensemble du dispositif de l'Institut
français est resté ouvert après avoir
connu une période de baisse drastique
sous le quinquen de François Hollande
allant parfois jusqu'à près de 50 % et
malgré ses missions reconnues l'Institut
français a connu une sagdation de son
budget à partir de 2017 quand on se
déplace à l'étranger on se rend compte
ainsi de la fragilation de ce réseau en
Europe particulièrement ce début de
haosse des crédits pour l'année 2024
était donc plus que nécessaire pour
inverser la tendance même si nous sommes
encore loin du compte c'est une analyse
que nous nous partageons avec le
rapporteur les besoins demeurent
importants aussi pour nos lycées
français notamment pour faire face à la
concurrence internationale on soulignera
que les objectifs fixés par le Président
de la République sont loin d'être
atteints en matière de développement
aussi il conviendra d'accentuer cette
hausse des crédits pour les années à
venir C quelques remarques ayant été
faites dans un temps et parti trop court
tout en soulignant le chemin restant à
parcourur notre groupe comme l'a déjà
dit Olivier cadiic votera l'
les crédits de cette mission je vous
remercie merci mon cher
collègue la parole est à Madame Martha
de Sidrac pour le groupe les
républicains et pour une durée de 5
[Applaudissements]
minutes vous avez la parole ma ch
cèg
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
spéciaux mes chers collègues l'état du
monde est préoccupant c'était vrai en
2023 cela le sera encore en 2024
instabilité crise pénurie et extrémisme
les mots qui affectent la géopolitique
actuelle sont nombreux et nous mettent
en tant que législateur face à des
décisions bien sûr il y a la décision de
donner plus de moyens à nos armées
l'emploi de la force n'est jamais
souhaitable en soi mais et peut s'avérer
parfois malheureusement nécessaire c'est
surtout un extrême recours lorsque
toutes les autres solutions ont été
épuisées ces solution c'est notre
diplomatie qui les met en œuvre au
quotidien elle défend les intérêts et la
place de la France dans le monde mais
également la paix la liberté et la
sécurité des Nations par son histoire sa
langue sa tradition notre pays a
développé une véritable culture
diplomatique au fil des siècles nos
différentes représentations ambassad et
consulat forment aujourd'hui le trè
réseau diplomatique du monde après les
États-Unis et la Chine avec les
équilibres géopolitiques instables que
nous connaissons c'est un atout un
élément majeur de notre
souveraineté la mission que nous
examinons semble soutenir budgétairement
notre diplomatie en effet ce PLF 2024
prévoit un budget en augmentation de 6 %
pour l'action extérieure de l'État dit
àe les crédits progressent en valeur de
28 90 millions d'euros par rapport 2023
une fois l'inflation déduite c'est un
effort significatif que je salue au
regard des enjeux et du contexte que
j'évoqué cependant cette augmentation
doit être utilisée de façon stratégique
en fléchant les nouveaux moyens vers des
zones géographiques précises et selon
des priorités politiques claires et bien
définies de même la politique extérieure
de la France n'est pas toujours d'une
grande lisibilité la récente crise au
Proche Orient nous le rappelle ces
moyens supplémentaires prennent place
dans le cadre d'annonce faite par le
président de la République aux états
généraux de la diplomatie en mars
dernier une augmentation du budget du
ministère de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères porté à 7,9 milliards d'ici
2027 ainsi que la création de 700
équivalents temps plein supplémentaires
il s'agit d'un effort conséquent mais
soyons vigilant car n'oublions pas le
contexte de ces promesses en juin 2022
fait inédit un mouvement social
d'ampleur a touché le ministère de
l'Europe et des affaires étrangèr sans
revenir en détail sur le décret qui a
mis le feu au poudre nous devrons nous
assurer que les annonces présidentielles
se concrétisent et n'ont pas été
prononcés pour faire du bien à qui veut
l'entendre malheureusement cela commence
mal les rapporteurs spéciaux de la
commission des finances relève que le
fléchage des crédits et des nouveaux
emplois est imprécis l'exécution de
cette mission budgétaire est donc à
surveiller au risque de n'avoir servi
qu'à apaiser temporairement les tensions
social avec une pointe d'ironie je
dirais qu'un tel scénario messianique a
déjà été vu par ailleurs je retiens né
aumoins l'intention d'un réarmement
diplomatique de long terme ce qui serait
salutaire depuis 30 ans les moyens
accordés à notre diplomatie ont été
grandement diminué de même que les
emplois publics dans ce domaine ont été
réduits de moitié la mission que nous
nous apprêtons à examiner défend notre
place de puissance diplomatique mondiale
et première dans l'Union européenne
c'est une vision importante car l'Union
européenne ne souhaite pas rester à
l'écart du sujet le déclin des capacités
diplomatiques de certains de nos
partenaires européens a mécaniquement
permis le renforcement d'une diplomatie
européenne mutualisée doté cette année
de près de 6 milliards d'euros de budget
c'est un atout sur lequel nous devons
nous appuyer sans feindre d'ignorer
certaines réalités en européenne
convaincu je souhaite rappeler la
nécessité de conserver une pleine et
entière autonomie diplomatique française
la voix de la France est écouté sur la
scène internationale depuis des siècles
pour faire valoir ses intérêts et sa
vision du monde cela doit continuer
ainsi en parallèle d'une diplomatie
européenne certes essentielle mais
agissant dans un périmètre d'action
différent la crise ukrainienne nous aura
montré les limites d'une diplomatie à 27
construire ensemble une Europe puissance
oui mais sans abandonner nos
spécificités nationales les Allemands
n'ont pas hésité à à protéger leur
souveraineté et leur intérêts vitaux
alors même que cela allait à l'encontre
de la position communautaire pour
conclure la fin de la guerre froide a pu
nous faire vivre dans l'illusion d'une
fin de l'histoire mais nous voyons bien
qu'il n'en est rien le monde dans lequel
nous vivons est multipolaire par semmet
de crise où centre choc tous les
extrémismes face à ce monde instable
nous devons pouvoir compter sur un
réseau diplomatique efficace ancré
experts parlant à nos alliés nos
adversaires nos ennemis c'est là le
premier R part de notre souveraineté tel
est selon moi l'état d'esprit qui doit
nous animer en examinant ces crédits de
l'action extérieure de l'État je vous
remercie merci chers
collègues la parole est maintenant à
Madame Catherine Colona ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
madame la ministre vous avez 15 minutes
de temps de parole je vous en
prie monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs sénateurs
permettez-moi tout d'abord de saluer la
qualité de vos interventions qui reflète
l'intérêt que porte votre Haute
assemblée au ministère de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères intérêt que
confirme le vote favorable de ce budget
à la commission des affaires étrangères
de la défense et des forces armées comme
à la commission des finances que je
remercie l'une et l'autre de leur
confiance vous l'avez tous dit et nous
le savons tous le contexte international
n'a pas été aussi complexe et dangereux
depuis des
décennies nous vivons dans un monde en
voie de fracturation brutale où les
menaces globales se renforcent et où les
crises s'additionnent et dans la seule
année écoulée le Soudan le Niger Israël
et Gaza nous ont ainsi rappeler combien
le kedarcé est au centre de la gestion
des crises à l'étranger un mot à ce
propos sur l'Arménie j'ai le plaisir de
vous annoncer l'engagement de 15
millions d'euros supplémentaires en
faveur de ce pays au titre de l'appui
humanitaire rendu possible par un
amendement au Sénat sur la loi de
finances de fin de gestion
2023 dans ce monde nos intérêts sont
partout contestés on le voit qu'ils soit
politique économique des menaces visent
nos ressortissants et nos emprises et
des menaces se déploient aussi dans le
champ numérique ou informationnel où
nous sommes la cible d'opération de
propagande et de
désinformation dans cet environnement
géopolitique durablement dégradé la
diplomatie est plus que jamais
nécessaire une diplomatie qu'il faut
réarmé pour faire face le budget qui
vous est soumis permet précisément de
poursuivre le réarmement de la mission
extérieure de l'État en 2024 ces crédits
devrai en effet atteindre
3344 millions d'euros en crédit de
paiement une augmentation de 293
millions d'euros par rapport à la loi de
finance initiale pour 2023 soit une
augmentation de 11 % du jamais vu je le
crois depuis
2005 alors que nos effectifs n'avaient
cessé de baisser ces trois dernières
décennies à l'exception de cette année
2023 je souhaiterait insister sur leur
hausse une hausse qui va nous permettre
de disposer de 165 ETP de plus qu'en
2023 où nous avions déjà obtenu 106 ETP
supplémentaires la répartition de ces
nouveaux effectifs concernera très
majoritairement la mission action
extérieure de l'État et prioritairement
à
l'étranger je veux vous dire aussi que
cette croissance de nos pour la 2e année
consécutive donc avec en outre des
perspectives favorables pour les budgets
2025 2026 et 2027 a entraîné un très net
changement d'état d'esprit chez nos
agents qui sont motivés par des
perspectives de carrière plus clair et
sont aussi plus confiant dans leur
avenir évidemment ce n'est pas anodin
alors où les crises s'accumulent et où
nous avons besoin de toutes nos
ressources une partie de ces nouveaux
ETP sera consacré à l'amélioration des
méthodes et outils de travail et au
programme de transformation de mon
ministère que j'ai décidé en juin
dernier dans le prolongement des états
généraux de la diplomatie et en
application des orientations fixées par
le Président de la République le 16 mars
preuve que l'augmentation de nos
effectifs n'est pas incompatible avec
une gestion dynamique des ressources
humaines nous continuerons de redéployer
des ambassades et services où la
pression est moindre vers de nouvelles
priorités géographiques ou
sectorielles mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs grâce au moyens de la mission
extérieure de l'État nous pourrons nous
concentrer sur quatre grandes priorités
que je souhaiteraiis aborder brièvement
première priorité les fonctions
politiques le programme 105 augmenterait
de 13 %. cela nous permettrait de
financer la nécessaire modernisation de
nos numériques mais aussi l'entretien et
le verdissement de notre exceptionnel
patrimoine immobilier qui va de paire
avec l'universalité de notre réseau que
nous avons fait le choix courageux de
conserver nous aurons ainsi à camperra
en
2024 la première ambassade à énergie
positive de notre réseau cette hausse
des moyens du programme 105 permettrait
aussi le renforcement de certains
services essentiels mais parfois
insuffisamment dotés comme souvent nos
chancelleries politiques ou encore la
consolidation de nos 25 postes de
présence
diplomatique ces moyens nous permettront
également de renforcer notre présence
dans le Pacifique avec l'ouverture d'une
nouvelle ambassade au Samoa vous le
savez comme annoncé lors de la tournée
du président de la République fin
juillet le programme 105 consacrerait
aussi 928 millions d'euros aux
contributions internationales et aux
opérations de maintien de la paix soit
une augmentation de 97 millions par
rapport à 2023 c'est indispensable pour
peser et agir 2è priorité l'influence le
programme 185 verrait ses crédits
croître de 8 % pour s'établir à 721
millions d'euros cette politique
d'influence se structure autour de deux
grands axes d'une part part le
développement d'un nouveau partenariat
solidaire avec le continent africain et
d'autre part la consolidation de notre
attractivité dans les autres zones
prioritaires particulièrement dans
l'Indo-Pacifique les établissements
autonomie financière principalement les
instituts français les instituts
français de recherche à l'étranger
disposeraiit de 8 millions de de plus
par rapport à
2023 de même les crédits pardonnez
les crédits alloués au réseau des
Alliances françaises qui sont un
instrument peu coûteux mais très
apprécié au service de notre rayonnement
augmenteraiit de 1005 d'euros soit une
hausse de 20 %. enfin une hausse des
crédits d'intervention de 24 milliards
24 millions d'euros permettrait de
renforcer notre réseau culturel et de
coopération sur les géographies
prioritaire dans un réseau qui a
beaucoup souffert des coupes répétés ces
dernières années dans un contexte de
compétition internationale accrue la
politique d'attractivité étudiante fera
en outre l'objet d'un investissement
important les crédits àoués aux bourses
pour les étudiants étrangers sera ainsi
porté à 70 millions d'euros soit 6
millions de plus par rapport à 2023 et
plus 9 % notamment pour faire venir les
profils les plus performants ajoutant
ainsi un objectifs qualitatifs à nos
objectifs chiffrés de 500000 étudiants
étrangers en 2027 objectif qui me semble
atteignable nous en sommes à
403000 euh lors de la dernière rentrée
3ème priorité la communication et la
diplomatie publique en matière de
communication et de presse les moyens
progresseraient de 2,2 millions d'euros
ces crédits visent à accroître le rôle
du ministère dans le pilotage de la
communication de la France à l'étranger
ainsi que les capacités de nos
ambassades dans des géographies
prioritaires comme l'Afrique et
l'Indo-Pacifique
nous souhaitons en effet doter le
ministère d'une nouvelle culture de la
communication stratégique avec deux axes
principaux la dynamisation et le
renforcement de notre présence sur les
réseaux sociaux et les médias pour
toucher de nouveaux publics le
renforcement de nos capacités de lutte
contre les manipulations avec le
développement de nos capacités de veille
sur les réseaux sociaux et enfin une
enveloppe de 600000 € sera prévue au
titre des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques pour activer un programme
spécifique d'invitation de journalistes
en vu de cet événement dont la réussite
est un enjeu majeur pour notre pays 4e
priorité les Français de l'étranger le
programme 151 qui regroupe ses moyens
bénéficieraient d'une trentaine de TP
supplémentaires en 2024 et verrait ses
crédits hors dépenses de personnel
croître de 24 millions d'euros par
rapport à 2023 soit une hausse de 17 7 %
pour atteindre un montant de 165
millions d'euros les crédits consacrés à
l'accès des élèves français au réseau
scolaire de la EFE et à la langue
française s'élèverit à un peu plus de
120 millions d'euros en 2024 soit une
hausse de 14,8 million d'euros par
rapport à 2023 cette enveloppe
permettrait de financer à hauteur de 118
millions les bourses des enfants
français dans le réseau de
l'enseignement français à l'étranger
pour permettre aux familles de faire
face à l'accroissement des frais de
scolarité et de plus 1 million et demi
d'euros serait alloué aux élèves en
situation de handicap je saisis cette
occasion pour confirmer nos objectifs
des objectifs ambitieux pour le
développement de l'enseignement du
français à l'étranger d'enseignement
français à l'étranger pardonnez-moi au
sein de lafe mais aussi par des
partenariats et nous allons redoubler
d'efforts à cette fin par ailleurs 1
million d'euros financerait
l'instauration du pass éducation langue
française annoncé par le président de la
République pour per mettre aux enfants
de nos compatriotes scolarisés
localement qui en ont besoin de se
remettre à niveau enfin les crédits àoué
au services publics consulairire ainsi
qu'à la modernisation de
l'administration consulaire augmenterit
de
200li8 afin d'améliorer la qualité des
services rendus au franceç et de
l'étranger notamment grâce à la
poursuite du déploiement de France
consulaire du vote électronique et de la
finalisation du registre d'état civil
électronique autant de chantiers qui
fonctionnent je crois à la satisfac
générale et continue de faire
l'attention de faire l'objet de notre
attention dans le cadre des politiques
prioritaires je vous remercie de vos
commentaires positif sur France
consulaire qui est d'ors et déjà un
succès et améliore l'accueil physique
bien sûr dans nos consilat en libérant
du temps disponible pour nos agents à
cette fin c'est avec la même
détermination que nous lutterons contre
les officines que vous avez mentionné
pour un meilleur service public
accessible à tous mais mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs tels sont les
grands axes du budget qui serait
consacré à la mission action extérieure
de l'État si votre rassemblé l'adopter
un budget qui nous permettra d'affirmer
nos principes nos intérêts et nos
solidarités dans un monde où c'est plus
nécessaire que jamais qui nous permettra
d'être un partenaire de confiance dans
la résolution des crises internationales
mais aussi d'être un pionnier en matière
d'enjeux globaux évidemment un moteur de
l'Europe laquelle demeure notre meilleur
levier de puissance je vous
remercie merci madame la
ministre je vous rappelle que pour cette
mission la Conférence des Présidents a
fixé la durée maximale de la discussion
à
3h15 nous devrions donc en terminer
l'examen aux alentour de
15h45 afin de pouvoir passer à l'examen
de la mission aide publique au
développement ce qui paraît possible au
vu du nombre d'amendement mais toujours
mes chers collègues avec un rythme
relativement soutenu d'examen de vos
amendements nous allons procéder à
l'examen des amendements portant sur les
crédits de la mission Action action
extérieure de l'État figurante à l'état
B article
35 premier amendement qui est le numéro
31 qui est présenté par Madame Nathalie
Goulet au nom de la commission des
finances de la parole madame la
rapporteur oui monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre notre commission
était très sensible évidemment à votre
budget à l'augmentation des crédits et
évidemment soutien que nous devons à
l'ensemble des diplomates qui animent
notre réseau euh cependant euh et donc
comme je l'ai indiqué à la tribune tout
à l'heure l'augmentation de 290 millions
d'euros faisant passer ce budget à 3
milliards et dei cette Haus est
extrêmement importante et interroge sur
la capacité du ministère de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères euh à consommer
l'ensemble de ces crédits d'autre part
le Sénat a défendu lors de l'examen du
projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques pour les années
2023-2027 une trajectoire d'évolution
des dépenses publ ambitieuse qui
permettrait de réduire le déficit à 3 %
du PIB depuis 2025 c'est la raison pour
laquelle notre commission a adopté un un
amendement de réduction de ces crédits 5
millions d'euros sur les dépenses
d'immobiliers en France et à l'étranger
du programme 105 5 millions d'euros des
dépenses de protocole et 20 millions
d'euros sur les dépenses relevant
d'autres crédits d'intervention madame
la ministre la commission des finances
est dans son rôle nous pensons que cette
réduction de budget ne devrait pas du
tout impacter les effets de la très
forte augmentation que par ailleurs nous
soutenons merci quel est l'avis du
Gouvernement madame la
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Madame la rapporteur le gouvernement ne
peut être que défavorable un amendement
qui déferait une grande partie du
renforcement de nos moyens que nous
avons appelé collectivement je crois de
nos vœux par ailleurs madame la
rapporteur vous saz que l'année 2024 va
être riche en événements internationaux
Sommet de la Francophonie chos
olympiques je parlelympique qui amène
plutôt un besoin de renforcement des
fonctions de protocole je vous
remercie merci Madame la Ministre la
parole est à Monsieur KNE pour
explication de vote oui merci monsieur
le Président Madame la Ministre si je
peux comprendre qu'il y a des économies
à faire je voudrais vous présenter les
raisons qui me poussent a m'opposer à
cet amendement don l'adoption amputerait
les crédits du programme 185 de 20
millions d'euros l'action 2 doit
traduire le très ambitieux plan présenté
par le Président de la République en
2018 je rappelle vise qu'il vise à
doubler les effectifs de l'enseignement
français à l'étranger tous les acteurs
du secteur et l'ensemble des collègues
des différents groupes politiques de ma
commission s'entendent pour affirmer que
cette ambition objectif va s'avérer
inatteignable faute de moyens dans ce
contexte suprimer encore 10 millions
d'euros à cette action aurait pour seule
conséquence d'éloigner encore un peu
plus la parole publique portée au plus
haut sommet de l'État il me semble
également pertinent de ah oui pardon
j'is oublié que les crédits de cette
action visent également à appuyer le
travail effectués par les instituts
français à travers le monde et nous
savons que six d'entre eux sont en très
grandes difficultés financière il me
semble également pertinent de maintenir
les crédits allués à l'action 4 relative
à l'enseignement supérieur et la
recherche la crise sanitaire a eu de
très graves retentissements sur les
modalités mobilité étudiante et ce n'est
que l'année dernière que les échanges on
peut reprendre le nombre de doctorants
étrangers en France était de 40 % 2019
il n'est plus que de 30 % alors que l'on
sait que 80 % des doctorants étrangers
restent en France après leur doctorat
cela fait donc plusieurs années que nous
nous plaignons dans cette assemblée de
la diminution des moyens et enfin nous
voyons un effort sensible de la part du
gouvernement il me semble donc
inapportun de voter cet amendement c'est
une fausse bonne
idée merci la parole est à Monsieur
temal pour explication de vote vous avez
la parole mon cher
collègue merci monsieur le Président euh
alors si nous avons bien entendu
effectivement madame la rapporteur sur
les raisons mais ça voudrait dire que on
pourrait s'amuser à ce jeu-là sur
l'ensemble des des crédits moi je que le
encore une fois je crois pas que c'est
une bonne méthode en fait de travail
nous nous voterons bien évidemment
contre cetement pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord la ministre l'a dit elle-même
l'année 2024 il un d'événements il est
normal que nous puissions que le
ministère puisse les réaliser il y a
aussi la question des bien sûr des des
dépenses immobilièires si on considère
que toutes nos ambassades tous nos
consulat fonctionne bien si on peut le
supprimer ce n'est pas le cas par
ailleurs et puis dernier élément qui à
mon avis est le plus important et qui
rejoint en partie ce qu'a dit mon
collègue précédemment peut pas dire il y
a quelques semaines il faut la France
puissance à l'international il faut fa
que le la France puisse porter la sa
voix porter sa vision porter ses
principes et puis réduire ce qui est
aujourd'hui au cœur de cet amendement là
puisque 20 millions donc les les 2 tiers
de cette dépense sont porté sur les
questions de de fait de stratégie
d'influence que ce soit sur la culture
est-ce qu'il faut plus de France à l'
International sur les à la fois ce que
nous représentons je rappelle que nous
avons le débat notamment sur les médias
nous avons le débat et le ministre le
moin l'évoqué tout à l'heure sur nous
avons une concurrence aujourd'hui par
rapport à d'autres pays qui utilisent
les médias qui utilisent quand je dis
médias notamment des réseaux sociaux
pour porter une voix notamment contre la
France nous avons eu le débat il y a
quelques semaines notamment sur avec le
ministre les deux ministres des Affaires
étrangères et de la défense sur la
question de la France en Afrique et on a
bien vu qu' un des sujets c'était
effectivement des campagnes de
désinformation contre notre pays et donc
là on propose concrètement de réduire de
bout à bout tous ces crédits là donc ça
n'a aucun sens et très honnêtement moi
je veux bien qu'on dise on a fait de
l'affichage mais 30 millions sur ce
budget là ne résout en rien le problème
des finances publiques pour le pour par
contre ça ça pénalise très sensiblement
à la fois le service de nos agents et en
même temps le rôle de la France dans le
monde donc nous montrons bienvement
contre cet
amendement merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur DEAE pour
explication de vote
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues moi je voterai avec
grand plaisir cet amendement parce que
c'est le seul c'est le seul qui cherche
à faire des économies dans les budgets
d'émission j'écouterai les autres
amendements mais tout ce que j'ai pu
regarder et lire avant ce sont que des
augmentations donc il y a un moment
donné où il faut quand même prendre
conscience de la situation dans laquelle
on se trouve et que dans un dans un le
budget de l'État qui est en déficit de
plus de 150 milliards on ne peut pas
avoir que des missions qui augmentent de
façon considérable et on a que ça sur
les 35 missions on doit en avoir 32 donc
on propose là la rapporteur et je la
trouve très courageuse je je moi je
soutiens ce courage parce que on propose
30 millions de diminution parort une
augmentation de 290 millions de la
mission c'estàd que c'est a à peu près
10 % de l'augmentation que sur lequel on
demande et pour avoir été rapporteur de
cette mission pour la commission des
finances les années précédentes j'ai
fait des propositions j'ai fait des
propositions d'économie qui n'ont à ce
stade pas été suivi des faits donc il y
a un moment donné où il faut quandême
prendre conscience de tout cela et
j'aimerais bien voir une note
stratégique sur notre action
diplomatique je l'avais demandé on l'a
jamais eu on continue à vouloir suivre
tous les lièvres en même temps donc il y
a un moment donné on va tous les rater
donc il faut il faut pouvoir se
concentrer moi j'aimerais bien qu'on se
concentre sur un certain nombre
d'actions et qu'on justifie les crédits
qui sont demander donc
honnêtement contrairement à ce que
beaucoup pensent un bon budget c'est pas
un budget qui augmente un bon budget
c'est un budget qui est documenté avec
des cibles bien identifié et sur
lesquels on met des moyens mais aussi on
dégage des économies sur d'autres
secteurs voilà pourquoi je voterai avec
grand plaisir cet
amendement merci la parole est à Madame
Duma pour explication de vot vous AZ la
parole mes cher collègue
oui merci monsieur le Président bon un
certain nombre d'arguments pour et
contre et notamment contre dans la
dernière intervention ont été donnés euh
moi je voulais dire que c'est un sujet
dont nous avons largement débattu en
commission euh donc les décisions sont
prises à bon ciant et oui Vincent deaet
a raison on est tous animés par
l'objectif de réduire les déficits
publics et de faire des économies on est
conscient bien sûr de cette nécessité
sauf qu'il faut les faire à bon et on
peut pas le faire à travers un discours
contradictoire donc moi je voudrais
redire que on ne peut pas voter cet
amendement de la commission des finances
qui est complètement inopportun et euh
qui n qui ne correspond pas au discours
que nous devons avoir
aujourd'hui merci la parole est à
Monsieur Leleu pour explication de vote
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers
collègues jusqu'à la chute du mur de
Berlin nous vivions dans un monde
bipolaire la chute du mur de Berlin a
entraîné une première phase
d'hyperpuissance américaine et
aujourd'hui nous voyons bien la montée
en puissance d'État qui joue un rôle
fondamament à travers notamment la
montée en puissance des bricks qui vont
accueillir six nouveaux pays à partir du
1er janvier alors que dans le même temps
aucun pays ne vient candidater pour
rejoindre le G20 de quoi s'agit-il il
s'agit ici de discuter d'un amendement
qui vise à baisser la puissance de notre
diplomatie culturelle et
d'influence dans le contexte de montter
en puissance de
ces états de ces groupes d'État qui
visent en réalité à remettre en cause
l'ordre mondial au travers de valeurs
fondamentales telleles que la démocratie
et l'état de droit si notre pays la
France n'est pas en première ligne pour
défendre cette diplomatie culturelle et
d'influence à travers les valeurs
fondamental que nous défendons personne
d'autre ne le fera avec la même
puissance hisorique et la
dimension
linguistique qui est notamment l'une des
lignes de crédit que vous supprimez dans
ce contexte je voterai contre
l'amendement de la commission des
finances merci la parole est à Madame
grehaum pour explication de vousz la
parole ma chère collègue bien entendu
vous allez bien vous douter que je
voterai contre cet amendement parce que
je trouve que plus que jamais nous avons
besoin d'une politique ambitieuse en
matière de solidarité internationale
ainsi que dans d'un R diplomatique à la
hauteur de nos ambitions dans le
contexte géopolitique actuel et nous
nous proposons justement par rapport aux
recettes on est toujours en train de
parler du de du manque d'argent d'un
déficit constant de toute façon on sera
toujours en déficit constant nous avons
des solutions nous au groupe
crcek de proposer justement des
nouvelles recettes par l'intermédiaire
justement travaillons sur les évasions
fiscales la parole est à Monsieur Marie
pour explication de vote vous AZ la
parole mon cher
collègue merci monsieur le Président euh
diminuer les les crédits tels que
proposés par cet amendement c'est tout
simplement ni la réalité du monde dans
lequel nous vivons les tensions
géopolitiques n'ont jamais été aussi
vives les puissances hostile au principe
démocratique s'arme militairement mais
pas seulement elle s'arme aussi
culturellement et elle développe leur
stratégie d'influence et nous avons
exprimé au sein de la commission des
affaires étrangères euh toute
sensibilité confondu euh la nécessité de
renforcer notre diplomatie et que
d'ailleurs le compte n'y était pas
totalement et qu'il aurait fallu aller
plus loin il n'est donc pas cohérent
aujourd'hui de baisser les moyens de
cette diplomatie alors que l'État de
droit et les droits humains que la
France porte grâce à son réseau
diplomatique n'est aujourd'hui euh plus
que jamais attaqué par nos adversaires
donc je pense qu'il faut voter contre
cet amendement merci la parole est à
Monsieur Lemine pour explication de
vote merci beaucoup monsieur le le
Président j'ai écouté attentivement les
orateurs précédents et euh monsieur de
c'est vrai nous avons besoin de
documenter les choses et d'ailleurs
petite réflexion peut-être pour pour
l'avenir je pense qu'on gagnerait
parfois à revisiter certains indicateurs
de performance pour avoir ir une
appréciation encore plus intéressante je
crois de de l'usage des crédits pour
autant ça a été dit il y a ce besoin de
réarmement qui est là dans de nombreux
domaines et c'est pourquoi les sommes
que les auteurs de l'amendement propose
de prélever je pense sont prélevés sur
des des domaines dans lesquels il y a
des besoins significatifs je m'explique
par exemple il proposit de prendre 5
million d'euros sur l'organisation des
conférences internationales or ce qui
est bien avec ce budget c'est c'est que
justement il y a le souci de
professionnaliser cette fonction cette
mission je peux vous dire
que voilà pour par exemple il y a 2 ans
on avait décidé de lancer ambition
Arménie tout ça c'est fait avec beaucoup
de bonne volonté avec un ambassadeur un
peu chef d'orchestre mais il aurait
fallu voilà d'autres ressources pour le
faire encore mieux et donc il y a le
ministère a a tiré les conséquences de
de ce type d'action de sa multiplication
euh et donc pour donner un voilà juste
une idée de de l'importance de ces
crédits de pouvoir les sanctuariser
raison pour laquelle effectivement nous
ne pourrons souscrire euh comment dire à
l'amendement et et pour le groupe RDP
nous voterons contre même si nous sommes
animés également du souci euh voilà d'un
exam d'un d'un d'un d'une utilisation
euh très attentive des donniers
publics merci je souhaite vous indiquer
que j'ai été saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public sur cet amendement la
parole est à Monsieur melouli pour
explication de vote alors je vais pas
reprendre tous les arguments qui ont été
soumis à à votre sagacité sur les
raisons de voter contre cet amendement
alors vous avez compris nous avons
votreons compre mais c'est pas aussi que
des moyens et on je je quand même je r
interpelle pardon le gouvernement sur
les propositions qu'on a fait je pense
qu'il faut changer de paradigme il faut
revoir notre stratégie en matière de
politique étrangère et retrouver la
singularité de la France et je pense que
nous serons pourons pas n pourrons pas
faire l'économie d'une réflexion et d'un
travail sur justement les acteurs les
enjeux de la politique étrangère de la
France ce n'est pas que des moyens les
moyens sont nécessaires mais c'est aussi
une vraie stratégie avec une vraie
vision du monde du 21e siècle donc nous
voterons contre cet amendement merci mon
cher collègue madame la ministre mes
chers collègues j'ai été saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public sur
l'amendement 31 déposé par la commission
la du Gouvernement est
défavorable le scrutin est
ouvert
ne demande à
voter le scrutin est
clos
nombre de votants
295 nombre de suffrages exprimés 294
pour 129 contre 165 le Sénat n'a pas
adopté mes chers collègues je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
14h40 pour la suite de l'examen de cette
mission la séance est
suspendue